Hey, everybody!
Hello, hello!
Today we're doing some vacation planning today.
But yes, I am planning on taking a vacation this year.
I don't know when.
But one of the places I've always talked about how much I really want to go back to.
And always saying how, like, oh, if I do a take-up vacation, it would be back to Hong Kong.
Because it's been, I think, almost 10 years since I've been back there.
And why are we whispering?
Because it's 9 p.m.
and I'm tired.
I'm tired.
It's like a mini Goodnight Dragoons right now.
So it'll be wintertime in Hong Kong.
Yeah, but, like, I'd rather be back there during the winter than during the summer.
I might not have been there for a while.
But I know how humid it is back there.
Yeah, no.
It's really bad.
It's usually, like, in mosquitoes, too.
I've been living in Canada for so long that I can almost forget how bad the mosquito problem was back there.
Back then.
And I'm pretty sure it's still pretty bad.
Just because, like, it's just, like, peak mosquito environment.
Because it's humid and it's really hot.
Uh, so, uh, because, like, for those who don't know, uh, they always...
I don't know if they still play this trailer.
Not trailer, sorry.
Play this ad.
Ha, ha, ha.
Like, I call ads a trailer.
But I don't know if they still play this ad on TV.
But there's a very, uh, oh, and it's surrounded by water, too.
And there's a very common Hong Kong ad, um, that plays, like, every, every, like, 10 to 15 minutes.
I think, I think, every ad break there is, this PSA, about making sure you empty the water around you in your home.
Or the mosquito will use it as a breeding ground.
Or to make sure to, uh, when it's raining, uh, to go home immediately.
And, like, clear all the water around you.
Uh, from your, like, pots and all, like, from your pots and bowls everywhere around you.
It, and it, it, this PSA was made during, like, the 1980s, I think.
Because, like, my mom used to tell me that, like, she used to watch this PSA, like, uh, when she was a teenager.
So, like, even further back in the 80s, I'm pretty sure.
Like, as a teenager or young adult, she would be like, um, always, like, I've seen this PSA for years.
And they, I don't know if they still use it, uh, because when I was there, they were still using it.
But, um, yeah, dengue fever is no joke.
So, uh, uh, I don't know if they remade it or anything.
But I know, like, malaria and dengue, yeah, malaria and dengue fever is, like, like, it's not a joke.
So, like, it's a way, uh, uh, to, like, uh, uh, make sure you, like, re-remember to, like, empty all of that stuff.
Yeah, um, it's really dengue.
Yeah, that's why I, that's why, like, I personally, I, I, I've also, like, my blood, my blood is, like, really, really attractive to mosquitoes, too.
Uh, so, uh, so, like, I remember back then, I would, uh, I would have to wear these, like, mosquito bands.
Like, the, the one that smelled, I don't even know what it's made of.
But my mom would make me wear these, like, mosquito bracelets, where it's, like, a very strong smell.
And I have to spray, like, mosquito repellent every fucking day that I go out.
And, um, and, like, uh, but I still, still get bit.
I still get bit by mosquitoes.
So, I'm not going back during the summer, too, because of that.
Uh, because it's been a very long, like, there's, I don't have, we don't have, really have mosquitoes in Canada.
Um, well, where I live, we don't really have mosquitoes here.
Uh, so, it's been a very, very long time, uh, since, uh, since I've been back.
And I, I, I, I know I scratch myself, too, when I get mosquito bites, because I cannot help it.
I have no self-control.
Every time I get bit by a mosquito, I would scratch myself, till, like, I have these little, like, scab wounds on, on my arms, or legs.
And then my mom would still, will rub on those, like, what are they called?
Those ointments and stuff.
The one where it's, like, okay, I'm gonna draw it, because I don't know what it looks, what it's called.
It's, like, this really common ointment, um, that people would rub on.
Yeah, and it stings, like, she doesn't, she didn't care that, like, uh, she didn't care that, like, I have an open fucking wound.
She would still rub this ointment on me.
And, um, and I, I don't want it.
I, like, I can't go back, guys.
I can't go back.
I don't know, I just know it's, it's, there's a red cap on it.
And this is what it looks like.
I'm gonna save it.
Let's see it.
I can't go back, guys.
Not again.
I am, I have no self-control.
I can't go back.
This is what it looks like.
I don't remember what it's called, though.
But it looks like this.
The, it's not a tire bomb.
It's something like this.
Um.
That you rub on your mosquito bite.
And, uh.
Someone will know what this is.
It's the rub one.
It was, like, that one.
It's very strong.
Like, when they, when you rub it on you, you feel it instantly.
And, uh.
And, I can't go back.
I can't.
Because I know I have no self-control.
I have no self-control.
And I know.
I know I will, I will scratch it.
I know.
But it's, like, um.
It's a stick.
I don't know what it's called.
But, and it's, like, a little stick thing.
And then, um.
It's, like, a little bent or whatever.
And then, uh.
Uh.
And then, yeah.
Yeah, my, my mom would, like, rub this fucker on me.
Um.
Anyway.
Uh.
What was I gonna say?
But, yes.
I'll be going.
Or maybe.
I was gonna think.
I found out that there's gonna be a.
Uh.
There's gonna be a Hatsune Miku concert in Hong Kong, too.
But then I know I'm not gonna be able to fucking get the tickets.
And that's the only thing.
And I was, like.
I was thinking.
I was, like.
Oh, man.
Like, I was, like.
Oh, my God.
There's a Hatsune.
But I know.
I know I won't be able to get the fucking tickets to get there.
I'll have to buy a scalper's ticket to get it.
And it's gonna be, like.
Um.
Yeah.
They're doing, like, a world.
They're doing a world tour.
Tour.
Or something.
And.
Yeah.
Um.
I feel like it's already...
I have to buy, like, scalp tickets or some shit to even have a chance.
No, Toki.
Don't enable Yimium.
There's no other way!
How else am I gonna get the tickets?
Guys!
How else?
There's no other way!
I don't know.
I maybe have to go to Mong Kok.
And someone will scalp the ticket.
Most likely.
I don't know if they'll still...
If they still do that.
But I remember, like.
When I went to...
I went...
I actually...
My very first concert was, uh...
Girls' Generation.
I went...
No.
Not Girls' Generation.
It's Wonder Girls.
My first ever concert...
Was actually in Hong Kong.
For Wonder Girls.
And it's...
I want nobody, nobody but you.
Ba-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Yeah, that was, like, the OG.
Um...
But that was, like, my very first concert I've ever been to.
But anyway, I was speaking of that.
Because, like...
I wonder if you can just show up.
And then, like...
You know those people that...
Because I remember when I went to that concert...
There were people selling tickets at the entrance.
Be like, tickets!
Tickets!
Ha-ha-ha...
Who wants to get in for tickets?
Ha-ha-ha-ha...
Ha-ha-ha...
Ha-ha...
Um...
So I don't know.
Maybe...
Maybe I can sneak my way in.
Um...
But I don't know.
I don't know when I'll be back.
But I want to go around this year, but I don't know exactly when I want to be there.
But yeah, I think the best time to go is during around the wintertime because it doesn't snow.
It doesn't snow, so I don't have to worry about it.
And when it's cold in Hong Kong...
When it's cold in Hong Kong, it's not that cold.
At least it's not Canadian cold weather.
Like, that's all that matters to me.
I'm just like, at least it's not Canadian cold.
So I'm fine with that.
I'm fine with that.
I don't have to deal with the humidity.
And it's not Canadian cold.
And there's no... I don't have to deal with snow too.
And I love the decorations that they do too.
The decorations are really pretty.
Um...
Uh...
Yeah.
It could be worse.
Um...
Yeah, I don't know.
I don't exactly...
Also, like, people are wondering...
I am planning on like...
I won't say like, vlogging.
Maybe vlogging.
And like, taking pictures and stuff.
And what my plans are when I do come...
Go...
Is that I'm gonna record some stuff.
And I'm gonna send it to like...
A...
Maybe like...
Cause I was thinking about 2D at first.
Doing a 2D.
But like...
I think it's easier if I send like...
A 3D...
To a 3D animator.
And just like...
Animate myself.
Like...
Exploring Hong Kong and stuff.
Uh...
And stuff.
And then like...
Have that like...
Being posted while I'm gone too.
Can I...
And send some footage.
Send some like...
Footages and stuff.
Over to a 3D animator.
To make some cute little scenes.
I don't know if I'll be like...
Shorts or something.
Or...
It will be like...
Shorts or like...
Video format.
But that's what I'm planning on doing.
While I'm like...
Gone.
So at least you guys get some...
Some sort of content.
And like...
It won't just be like...
Um...
You know, I won't just be like...
Missing, missing.
Cause I don't know if I'll be able to stream.
I don't know.
Depending.
Cause I'll most likely be...
At...
You know.
I don't know.
I don't know if I'll do that.
Cause I wanna...
I won't be...
I don't wanna do a BNB.
I'm too scared.
I hear too many horror stories.
Of people who rent BNBs.
Now.
Because like...
A lot...
There's just too many rules.
When it comes to...
Like...
I feel like it got...
A lot trickier.
And stuff.
Renting like BNBs.
Because there's so many rules now.
About it.
And like...
Like...
And then like...
If you don't clean it.
You'll be charged like...
Uh...
You'll be charged like cleaning fees.
And stuff.
And...
Um...
Yeah.
So...
I'm too scared to do BNBs.
I've never done one before.
But I've heard too many stories about like...
Uh...
BNBs and stuff.
Like...
Around the world.
So like...
Uh...
I don't know.
I'm like...
Most likely...
I'm not gonna rent...
Not gonna do a hotel.
But I'm gonna do like the...
What's it called?
Apartment hotels.
I don't know if you guys ever heard about apartment hotels.
But I rented one of those in Japan, and I know they do have some of them in Hong Kong, but it's basically like... I don't know if it's... I think it's like a lot cheaper.
But it's a lot cheaper, but you just have to take care of the... Yes, service apartments!
Yes!
Yes, service apartments!
They're a lot cheaper than hotels if you're renting for a long stay.
And you can cook there, and it gives a lot of space and everything.
And I believe there's a washing machine too.
But yeah, I'm thinking of trying to do that.
I also want to go to Hong Kong Disneyland to see the new Frozen World.
I heard it's the... What was it?
It's the... 20th anniversary?
I can't believe it's the 20th anniversary.
Oh my gosh!
I was watching a video earlier of, like, the 20th anniversary for Hong Kong Disneyland and the stuff they have.
But I'll show you guys the video.
Whoops.
I'll show you the video.
This is a YouTuber I like to watch that gives me, like... That gives me, like, I guess amusement park updates and stuff.
Let's see.
Todd, okay.
I'll... Okay, so... Alright.
Let me see.
I'll show you the videos.
React time.
Oh baby!
It's time to react!
Okay.
Let's see.
Alright, this is a YouTuber I watch.
His name is TDR Explorer.
I like to watch his stuff when he talks about, like, amusement parks.
You can definitely feel the energy in here.
Yay!
My soul is enjoying this.
Oh my god.
What is this?
Yay!
No, we're not.
We're not gonna watch the whole hour, guys.
This is, like, merch and stuff.
Yay!
Merch!
Okay, most likely I won't buy any.
I don't know.
Also, this is so popular.
Like, this character.
I don't... This is... Okay.
Wait, I need to show this... This character.
I don't know what they're called.
Um...
But they're very popular in Asia.
Like, in... I know, like, in Japan, these guys are really popular.
They're very popular too.
But they are not... No, they're... They're... No, they're like... It's like the... They're like...
This, like, this bear?
Is it Doofy?
Is it... Duffy or something?
I don't...
I don't... I don't... Yeah, Duffy and Friends!
Yes!
Duffy and Friends!
They're incredibly popular, but only in Asia.
Because, like... I don't... I don't know why.
They're not... They're not, like, famous at all outside of Asia.
Like, people in NA have no idea what they are.
But these guys are so popular.
Unless you're, like, a Disney adult or some shit.
But... Unless you're a Disney adult.
Because I've seen, like, pin collectors, uh...
Really liking Duffy and Friends.
That, you know, my favorite...
My favorite pin collecting channel that I like to watch.
Because, like, I live vicariously through them.
Like, I don't understand their hobby, but it's... They're... They have really nice enthusiasm.
Um... But... Uh...
Duffy and Friends are, like, incredibly popular in Asia.
And, um...
And, uh... I don't know why they never, like, made it out of Asia.
I guess because they're just...
It's just... Like, I... For me?
I'm gonna say it.
It might be a hot take.
But I find them very generic.
I...
I'm sorry.
I... I just find them very generic, in my opinion.
But I... I'm sorry.
But I know they're very famous and popular in Asia.
I'm sorry.
I'm...
Cookies and chocolate crunch.
All right.
Yay!
I got this land!
I got...
Okay.
Now for the actual real content.
This is what I want.
This is... This is what I want.
This... Look at this.
I want this.
This is what I'm here for.
Oh my god!
Yo.
Of course.
Here's my Disney-themed food!
What the fuck is that?
Look!
Oh my god!
That's a tea set!
That's so cute!
Oh my god!
Look at this tea set!
That's actually so cute!
Look at all that food!
Okay, but you gotta admit, that actually looks really, really good for a tea set.
I'm gonna order this just for...
I'm gonna go there by myself.
And I'm like, I want the tea set for two.
And they're like, oh, is anyone gonna show up?
I was like, no.
I said, a tea set for two.
Oh, there's a buffet, too.
Did I stutter?
It's for me and myself.
I am the two!
Oh my god, that's...
I don't know what that is, but I'm getting sugar over, though, just looking at it.
Uh, don't make me...
Don't make me repeat myself!
Are these jello shots?
Like, what the fu- Jello shots for kids!
Holy shit!
Okay, that looks bougie as hell, though.
Aww, it's like...
It's like a little pastry.
What is that pineapple?
Is that beef wellington?
Okay, that...
I'm sorry, but that looks disgusting.
I'm...
What is that?
What...
Is that a fucking...
A ball of pasta?
Wait, what is that?
Okay...
Okay, this is cute.
The...
The mongol bodine.
I love the...
Mango...
Is that a ramen ball?
What the fu- is that?
But this looks cute, because that's a mongol bodine.
I like that.
That's shaped as a...
Shaped like a Winnie the Pooh!
So much for us.
Okay, I'm sorry.
We're...
We're definitely...
This is what...
This is what I'm looking forward to.
This is exactly what...
This is where I'm spending 80% of my time in Disneyland.
Because, like, there's no wait time in Hong Kong.
I'm sorry.
There's...
For those who don't know...
Hong Kong...
There's no wait time in Hong Kong Disneyland.
I don't know...
Yeah, I'm pretty sure.
There's no wait time there.
So...
We're gonna be able to go to any of the rides so fast.
Yeah, it's so cute.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Look at that.
Is that full fucking chicken just for me?
Oh!
That's a...
Oh my...
Bro!
Oh my god!
That Thai chicken is just for me, I guess.
Food in favor.
Whole ass chicken!
And ribs!
Yeah, family...
I don't know if you heard...
Well, I don't know if the video's loud enough.
He said there's a lot of family feast meals.
And I'm like, yeah!
I'm the family!
A solid snake!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Food fun!
All the merch sales going to Doki's and food amusement fest!
Oh yeah, there's Zootopia stuff.
Zootopia is, like, incredibly popular in Asia.
I don't know if you guys know that.
Always because it's, like, furry related.
And, like, um, and we just like cute animals.
I swear, like, cute mascots and stuff.
I swear, like, uh, like, it's like how, like, Stitch is, like, incredibly popular in Asia in general.
But yeah, Zootopia is, like, very, very popular in Asia in general.
I think it's just, like, related to, like, mascots and stuff.
Like, we just love mascots in general.
That is a really cute cupcake.
Okay, I...
This apparently is $688.
Look.
I don't know that's...
That has to be in Hong Kong dollars.
There's no way.
There's no way this is, like, 688 US dollars.
This has to be, like, HKD.
I don't know how much that is in USD, but this should be, like, 688 HKD.
And, like, the thing is...
I know Disney that...
Because, like, some of you guys are, like, uh...
Some of you guys might be, like, oh, but amusement park food is, like, not that great and overpriced.
No, no, that, like...
Asia...
Asia amusement park food is, like, so much better.
Like, it's actually, like, better.
Like, it's a whole different level compared to, like, NA amusement park food.
Because someone did, like, a comparison between the two...
Like, the two Nintendo World...
Nintendo World, like, Toastal Cafe and stuff.
Um, it's still overpriced.
No, 100%.
It's still overpriced.
But at least it doesn't taste like cardboard.
You know?
And...
At least it doesn't taste like cardboard.
But it's, um...
It's still pretty good.
Oh, my God.
That's crazy.
I want to order this and be, like, no strawberry.
Okay, that...
That's a tea set right there.
Oh, my...
Okay, that tea set is so cute.
Because it looks like it came from a cartoon.
Oh, my God.
That's true.
Ate the family.
Therefore, she is the family.
Yeah.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
Look at this tea set.
That's so cute.
The burger looks like it came out of a cartoon.
Yeah.
It even has, like, the little burgers.
It looks like they came out of the cartoon.
Hosted by Coca-Cola.
It's sponsored by Coca-Cola.
Yeah, it's like a little Ferris wheel.
Yeah.
Aw, these little mini ones.
I'm sorry.
Duffy is so generic to me.
All the Duffy fans.
Please don't...
Please, guys.
Please don't hate-raid my channel.
I'm sorry, Duffy fans.
No, he's just looking through, like, the options and stuff of, like, what kind of food there is.
But, like...
There's, like...
Please don't castle me.
Oh, and I saw, like...
I think this is by Sawaski.
This looks like...
I don't know if you guys know this, but Sawaski is incredibly popular in Hong Kong.
I'm pretty sure the crystals are from Sawaski.
You see Sawaski scores?
I don't...
I don't know.
Sawaski is everywhere.
Show us the rides.
Um...
I think it's Sawaski.
It looks like Sawaski...
Sawaski crystals.
But they're, like, everywhere.
Okay.
Let's see.
I hope...
Okay.
I hope the...
They're not...
He's not too loud and it's not too quiet.
The rides?
Uh...
I don't even know if he's good on any of the rides.
Oh, my God.
Look at all this merch.
There's so much merch.
Look at all this.
What is this?
What is he opening?
Oh, my God.
Blind boxes.
I will buy it.
What the fuck is he opening?
Oh, my God.
They're trash cans.
It's a gotcha Tissy land bins.
It's, like, actual gotcha trash.
Oh, my God.
I, like, realized they're, like, it's a fucking trash cans.
Like, out of any Disney stuff you get, you want to gotcha the fucking trash can.
Like, I, like, garbage pool heaven.
My 24 karat gold, gold trash can.
It's a little trash gotcha.
My favorite Disney blind box.
The double mystic.
Oh, my God.
I want to see him eat this.
I, how do you eat this, though?
How the fuck?
That's crazy.
Um, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
All right.
Yeah!
It's, like, I'm there.
Get the feet off the sand.
No, I'm sorry.
They think they go to the school or something.
When did he eat this?
Holy shit, he ate so much.
Okay.
Back to...
Yeah.
Oh, ho!
Yeah!
You don't belong here.
Duffy.
He thinks he goes to the school or something.
Yeah!
All right.
Skiff.
Too much.
Aw!
The outfits are so cute.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
This is just all Duffy meet and greets.
And then there's the castle.
Is he still eating?
Oh, my...
Back to food.
Back to the real content.
He's...
It's time.
He went back for it in seconds.
Um, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
That's good.
I need to know about this.
Oh, wait.
Is this...
Oh!
Wait.
That's so cute.
What is this?
Oh!
They're pork buns.
That's cute.
Wait.
That's really cute.
I want that.
I didn't...
This is, like, apparently a buffet or some shit.
Yeah.
It's a...
It's a buffet.
I think it's nice.
It's nice that they do this.
I think that's really, really cute.
We don't want to see.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
For those who want to actually see it.
I'll show you guys an actual ride from Hong Kong Disneyland.
Um.
I'll show you the...
Okay.
This one's really famous.
Mystic Manor Hong Kong Disneyland.
I've been to Mystic Manor before.
Um.
Like I said, like...
There's no actual, like...
Lines for Hong Kong...
I don't know if it's different.
Is it different now?
Because, like, back then...
Back then, there was, like, barely any lines.
You can literally just go through instantly.
But maybe it's different now.
Because it is the 20th anniversary.
So maybe it's different now.
But usually, like...
Usually, it's very easy to, like, finish Hong Kong Disneyland in, like, a couple of hours.
Alright.
I'll show you guys.
This is, like...
What?
This is, um...
This is, like...
Uh...
Cues aren't bad.
Yeah, it's good.
You may wait maybe a bit during peak times.
I wonder what...
What's peak time?
I don't...
I went there, like...
Three times.
But, um...
I went there three times and...
Um...
And...
Never had to wait too long for it.
Alright.
I'll show you.
I'll show you...
I'll show you Mystic Manor.
So, this is basically, like...
Their version...
Instead of the Haunted Manor...
The Haunted Manor...
We have the Mystic Manor.
Um...
And, uh...
Oh, make sure it doesn't line up with a school trip.
Oh!
If it's, like...
Yeah, if I go during the winter, it'll be fine.
Because, like, every...
All the kids will have to go to school.
Um...
Oh, let me know about the sound.
Oh!
But, one thing I really want to go is Ocean Park.
Okay, we all skip here.
Is the sound okay?
Or is it too loud?
Let me know.
So, like...
Basically...
You're in some old man's house.
And...
Yeah.
I like Ocean Park more.
Ocean Park is really, really fun.
You get...
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure I'll get demonetized.
But, that's okay.
I want to see the pandas!
I haven't seen the pandas in so long!
Apparently, they got a third...
Wait.
How long do pandas live for?
Okay, this is fucked up for me to ask.
But, like...
Because, like...
Are they the same pandas?
I hope they're the same pandas.
This is Mystic Mani!
Because I saw them when I was, like, a kid.
So...
Oh, okay, there.
Look.
That's good.
So, it's the same pandas that I saw.
So, you're basically...
So, this monkey's a little shithead.
And he, like...
He basically, like...
Uh...
Opens a magic box and makes everything come alive.
Yeah, there are more...
There are six now?
Did they make babies?
Oh, my God!
Did they do it?
Wait.
Did they actually make babies?
Or, like...
Were they sent new pandas?
Oh, my God!
When I was there, there was only two!
They did it!
Congrats on the sex.
Oh, my God!
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom!
This ride actually freaked me out.
Because, like I said, I...
I...
Really hate animatronics in general.
And I wasn't...
I didn't know what I was watching.
Like, I didn't know...
I didn't know exactly...
What I'd be, like...
Um...
Experiencing when I'm, like...
In this ride.
So...
I was...
I didn't know that they were, like...
All the animatronics are, like...
Up that close to me.
And it freaked me out a lot.
Like, now- this is- like, these are okay, but then, like, the further you go in, the more- the more stuff happens.
And I was, like, not happy about it.
I was not hap- like this, that- that actually scared me.
I remember when that happened, and that fucking scared- This one, too, I was not happy.
I-
But- because it got dark, too.
So I was, like, oh, I was not happy.
I- I-
I, like, closed my eyes for, like, half of this ride.
How small was I?
I won't- I won't tell you the age.
I was just saying... that... um...
I was... maybe at... maybe older than ten.
Yeah!
I hated these, too.
Okay, no, this one's here, which- not this one.
Um, it was- not- there's, like, not this one, but there was one here that I was not a fan of.
Bum, bum.
I'm speeding it, though.
I'm gonna speed it a little.
I love this channel, by the way.
Attraction 360?
I live vicariously through this channel.
This room.
I didn't like this room.
I did not like this room.
I did not like this room!
This room?
Oh my god.
Because, like, these guys- oh, I- I- I don't like the tiki stuff.
I actually have, like- it- it- it does not look very friendly.
Because, like, there's a reason why.
Um, I told this story before, but when I was li- very little, um, for some fucking reason, my parents owned this li- this, like, little diet box thing, filled with tiny-ass tiki mask.
I don't even know their tiki mask or, like, aboriginal mask.
Um, but, like, uh, I don't remember.
And they would put it- hang it on the stairs to the basement.
And then whenever I see it at night, it's- I, like, freak out.
Because, like, it, like- it, like, gives me nightmares and stuff.
But, I did not like this- this area.
I- I closed my eyes for this.
I closed my eyes for, uh, for this part of the ride.
Because I was not a fan.
But, yeah.
I will say, this was cool, though.
This was really cool.
I like that.
Because it, like, it's like, you know, Wukon and, uh, Wukon statue.
Why are they- because he's a fucking asshole!
He did this!
Yeah, this is Mystic Manor.
That is a very short- I mean, it's, uh...
It's, like, a five minute ride.
It's pretty decent, I think.
I think it's pretty decent.
And everything, uh, and then everything, uh, went okay.
Yay!
Oh my- I'm sorry.
I know, like, we were supposed to be vacation planning.
But, like, that, like, reminded me about something.
But, I have to show you guys.
I know we were supposed to be vacation planning.
But, I was gonna look up Ocean Park stuff.
But, I- Okay, Sing...
Universal Studios.
You know there's a Universal Studios in Beijing now?
I did not realize they opened the Universal Studios in Beijing.
There's a Disneyland in Shanghai.
Which I love- I would love to go as well.
Um, which is great because my, uh, my 3D studio, um, is actually located in Shanghai.
So, like, it's a good excuse for me, you know, when I do my 3D debut.
It's a good excuse for me to, you know, go to Shanghai Disneyland.
Um, but, like...
Okay.
I'm definitely gonna get demonetized here, but...
But, it's actually really cool.
But, they have a sing show.
Um, in...
They have a sing show at Universal Studios in Beijing.
And I was- Okay, but, like...
Alright, I'll show you, like...
So, like, it's, like, Chinese sing.
Where they introduce everything in Chinese.
And then singing in English.
But, like, it's actually so cool.
It's so fucking cool.
Okay, wait.
Okay, this...
Okay.
Oh, you can't see it properly.
Oh, sorry.
Let's do this one.
This is better.
This guy's closer.
Alright.
This is better.
Alright, here we go.
Look at this.
The costumes are great, by the way.
Until, like...
The final one.
Which looks a little freaky.
Yeah, it's an animatronic.
But, the rest are, like, actual costumes.
Yeah, it's- it's Mandarin.
Look at this.
Yeah!
Woo!
Let him go!
That's my boy!
Okay, you can't see it very well here.
Because, like, the thing is covering it.
But...
But, like...
I think he's singing, too.
I'm pretty sure.
I don't think this is a recording.
It does not sound like a recording recording.
Yeah!
I'm still standing.
In a mudslide.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure.
It doesn't sound like a recording recording.
Yeah, yeah.
It's like, one lifts.
Okay, but look at this.
I like how, like...
They're so big.
Yeah, and then...
Okay, all right.
And then there's the elephant here.
I think that's crazy.
Like, that it's able to...
Not crazy, but, like, it's actually so cool.
To see...
To see, like...
The costume moving, too.
Like, the mouse.
But I know this is not a recent thing.
Because, uh...
Because I know, like...
The Disney mascots do that, too.
Where the mouse move.
And the...
The eyes can blink, too.
Okay.
All right.
I will show you.
Like, all these costumes look so good.
And then we get to the Scarlett Johansson porcupine.
The scene's great, though.
I love the scene, though.
But...
I just.
There's just something about...
I think it's the eyes.
I think it's the...
I think.
I think it's the eyes.
Maybe.
I...
Yes!
It's the eyes, right?
It's the eyes.
It's more than just the eyes.
The thing is, everything else looks... I love everything.
Okay.
Okay, it's like... She's just so out of place.
She just looks so out of place.
With everyone else.
That's really it.
That's what I was like.
Everything else looks amazing, though.
I mean, it looks fun.
It's just... It's just the eyes.
I can't... I don't know what it is about it.
It might emerge.
One of those things is not like the other.
Yeah, I like the... I love... Like, he knows what he's doing.
She does, too!
It's just... The costume is not... Really helping her right now.
Yeah, the costume is just not helping her.
But I wanted to show you guys this.
I... I didn't know what Universal... Universal is now in Beijing, though.
Universal Studios.
That's so cool.
I want to go there, too.
Um... Yeah... She's just set up to fail.
Unfortunately.
Um... But... Oh, that's Ocean Park.
What is... What is new at Ocean Park?
Anyway.
Uh... Okay.
Water World.
We're not going there.
My God.
I don't want to do any of the roller coasters.
I'm really bad with roller coasters.
Um... Ocean Park Attraction Guide.
Alright.
Let's see.
Yay!
Ocean Park!
No!
I hate the... I don't like roller coasters.
Penguins!
Disneyland opened in 2005, but instead...
Okay.
The main gift shop, as well as lots of attractions.
I know that...
This is very unique.
Okay.
Let's see.
Whiskers Harbor.
Amazing Asian Animals.
Polar Adventure.
Thrill...
I know, like...
I got really tired walking around this, though.
Because I was...
I was there during the summer.
It was so fucking hot.
I don't like roller coasters.
I'm like...
I don't like...
I have fear of heights.
Um...
Oh, it's so cute.
Aquarium!
Ocean Park sucks now?
Oh!
It was so pretty back then.
It was so fun back then.
Oh, Halloween events are always really fun.
I don't...
I don't want to go on...
I just don't want to go on the roller coasters.
Because I'm not a fan of roller coasters.
Oh, panda, panda, panda.
Oh, my God!
I should go to the monkey...
Monkey Mountain!
Okay, sorry.
I don't have ADHD.
I don't know...
I've never been to Monkey Mountain.
But there's a mountain in Hong Kong...
That's just filled with monkeys.
And you're not supposed to, like...
Feed them anything.
Or they'll fucking steal your stuff.
Oh, it's an animal's crucial conservation effort...
That can help save this particular species.
Sky, thank you for the rain.
Thank you, thank you.
That will take you back to the retro era...
Oh.
Oh, that's cute.
I can enjoy the photo-friendly area...
Monkey Mountain has monkeys...
I don't know what it's actually called.
I don't know what the...
Those monkeys...
I've never been there!
I've only passed...
I've only, like, passed...
Like, passed the mountains...
And seen the monkeys walking on the road.
And then my parents would be, like...
My parents would be...
I'd be like, I want to go to Monkey Mountain.
And then my parents would be like, no, you don't.
I'm like, oh, my God.
I want to go to Monkey...
Like, we would pass it by the...
The taxis.
Taxis, like, you know, like the red taxis, the red calves.
We'll be in the red cab and then we'll pass by Monkey Mountain.
It's like, I want to just go see the Monkey Mountain.
I want to see the monkeys at Monkey Mountain.
I heard like, no, you don't.
You don't.
Don't bite you.
No, you don't, little doki.
I choose from a selection of sea creatures, including seahorses, dolphins, sharks, and goldfish.
This is a great attraction for all the family.
to enjoy.
Next, we have Sloth and Friends Studio.
It's a bit featuring the lovable slow-moons, along with macaws, kinkajus, and pythons.
And they are right.
As long as I don't feed them, it'll be fun, right?
Oh, the cable.
I don't want to go through the cable car.
I know like a lot of people, like this is like an iconic attraction, the cable car.
But like, I, I, my fear of heights actually, I, I don't know if I told you guys this story before, but, um, when I was traveling with my parents in Europe, we, we took these like, we have to take a cable car up to like this very giant mountain, um, like this snowy mountain,
and like, if you guys didn't know, like, the higher the altitude is, the harder it is to breathe, and like, apparently my heart was beating too fast, and I couldn't, I was having a lot of trouble breathing and stuff too, um, while we were going up, so then my parents,
like, my dad had to take me back down, because like, the altitude, I, it was the altitude, and like, I was just too, too scared of the heights.
Um, but like, I'm just really bad with heights in general.
I find, for me, it's just scary, because like, I'm not really good with heights in general.
Okay.
Show me the pandas!
I wanna see the pandas!
Yay!
I was here!
Yes!
I see these, uh, Yingying and Lele!
Why is there only two?
Where is this, the four others?
You can find Yingying and Lele, two amazing giant...
Where are the four other pandas?
I was told there were four, six pandas.
...in their specialized habitat.
You can also see some red pandas, and the largest amphibian in the world, a Chinese giant salamander.
Oh!
Our animal exhibits include Gator Marsh, showcasing rare Asian alligators, and finally...
The four others are VIP?
VIP?
I will become VIP.
I'll be like, um, do you know who I am?
I am a VTuber!
Hahaha!
The two walking trails include the Emerald Trail that features lots of different birds and beautiful...
That's cute!
...making it...
...is Toto the Loco, a mini train ride that takes you on a small adventure.
Where do I ride on this train?
...is perfect for the younger visitors.
Hahaha!
Oh, wait, there's meerkats?!
...and includes interactive elements...
I didn't know there were meerkats...
...that the younger visitors will love.
Next up is Castle of Red, a maze of tunnels, climbing nets, and fun, interactive animals...
I think this is for children.
...and lots of people...
...a mini-shirt.
Hahaha!
...a mini-shirt!
Oh my god!
Yeah, I'm not going on that ride!
...and the ocean...
...a great...
...is the South Pole spectacular.
What's this?
PENGUINS!
...penguins...
...from three different species...
...including king penguins, rock hopper penguins, and white bonneted gentoo penguins.
If you love these animals, then I would suggest dining in the nearby restaurant called Tuxedo...
...that offers a panoramic view of the beautiful birds as you die.
That's so cute!
I want to eat natural penguins.
Now head to the Arctic box.
Hey, there's arctic boxes now?
That features the elusive tundra predator.
The information boards explain the key behaviors of the species along with the impact of humans...
Oh, that's cute!
The final attraction in Polar Adventure is the North Pole Encounter.
This exhibit showcases two huge pacific walruses and spotted seals.
Visitors are able to view these...
Oh my god!
It's the fat seals!
I love these!
Okay, I love these seals because when they squish up against the glass, it's so silly.
I love seeing those fat fucks!
We now head to the next one, Roll Mountain.
A carnival...
Oh, it's like a little carn...
Yeah, it's like a little carnival!
This one is the Ultramax flat ride called The Flash.
This will spin you 22 meters into the air.
This one, I don't mind.
This one, I don't mind as a ride.
I know...
I can just close my eyes and feel the wind.
That's fine.
Never mind.
It goes upside down.
I'm not fine with that.
Never mind.
I take it back.
I thought it just goes like right to the left, but it goes upside down.
I'm not fine with that.
I'm...
Never mind.
That is not fine.
I'm fine with this.
I'm fine...
Yeah, I don't go upside down.
Okay, these are like...
This is a classic.
This is a classic ride.
I like how all these are just classic...
I like that they're all just classic rides.
Oh!
I love this marine world.
Oh, so this is like part of the aquarium stuff.
What the fuck?
Okay, I was gonna be like, that's so, like, out of nowhere, you know?
It's like, oh, look at all these animals.
And it's like, welcome to the demon grove.
And I'm like, what?
Where did this come from?
Oh, I don't like this.
I don't like that.
That is the bad part of the neighborhood.
Like, we were talking about cute animals and, like, and, like, penguins.
It's like, welcome to demon grove.
Took a wrong turn.
Welcome to Japan.
What is this?
Wait, what is it?
Wait, what?
What the?
Oh!
Laser tag.
What the fuck?
In my ocean?
Where is the ocean involved?
Like, the alien egg, wait!
There was the alien egg.
Did you guys see that?
And a massive force of up to 4Gs, this is certainly not...
What?
What is it called again?
Wait, I need to see what this is called.
1,800 lab?
You either head to the cable car at the top part of the...
Yeah, Xenomorph!
Or for a shorter way, you can head further on up to the Ocean Express, located in the rainforest.
Each night, there are two nighttime shows in the Aqua City Lagoon, near the entrance of the park.
First is Visions of Comic-Con, showcasing the city's character, and evoking a spectrum of emotions, with the use of lights and fountains.
And the second show is Soul of the Ocean, that uses a special mix of original music, projection mapping technology...
That's so cool!
Oh my god, that is scary!
I...
That is so scary, I'm sorry.
That's...
Oh, is BGM a bit loud?
Come here...
Oh, whoops, sorry!
I forgot I had BGM.
I'm...
I'm sorry.
I didn't even realize I had BGM.
Okay, so...
I don't know.
That...
That last part was pretty scary.
Okay, what's it called?
1-1800...
Lab?
1-800...
Ocean Park?
What's it called?
1-800 Lab?
180 Lab.
There's no videos of it?
How the fuck am I supposed to know?
What, like...
What...
Is it a new rat?
What is that?
I wanna know what it is.
1-800...
180 Laboratory.
I just wanna know what's inside it.
A scary index.
A hidden lab...
Okay, near...
That's...
There's no info.
I just wanna know, like...
What's inside...
Wait, no one has ever filmed...
I guess you're not allowed to film the inside?
There's no way.
What?
You're not allowed to film the inside of 1-800 Laboratory?
Or 1-80 Laboratory?
What does it look like?
Don't open dead inside.
I just wanna know...
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm looking at the pictures...
And it's like...
It's pretty freaky.
Not gonna lie.
Never mind.
This...
It's actually like...
Horror, horror.
It's...
I looked at the pictures...
And I'm not a fan.
I'm sorry.
Like...
I'm...
I'm scared.
Like...
It might look actually...
It actually looks scary, scary.
There's a video trailer of it.
I'll show you guys.
Let me see.
Holy shit.
What is this video trailer?
This is an ad for a fucking ride.
What?
Bro, what the...
This is a good-ass fucking ad.
Quality.
So why is it like this?
What the fuck?
Now she's outside?
Okay.
What I don't understand...
Is that...
When...
In the video...
They were like...
Oh...
Um...
You're trying to stop an infection.
And then I'm like...
This does not look like an infection.
This...
This looks like straight-up horror.
Like...
What the fuck?
I thought I played laser tag.
Oh my god.
Oh look.
Everything's okay.
Every...
Oh.
Everything is not okay.
They change theme every year?
Oh.
Maybe for now it's laser tag.
This is a very aggressive infection.
Yeah.
Because I was like...
Wait.
What?
I thought...
I thought there was something about...
Oh.
Okay.
I'm reading this.
It's cause like...
When this...
This laboratory came out...
They basically dedicated...
Based...
Dedicated the entire thing...
Based off of like...
A haunted school.
So like...
Yeah.
So...
Um...
So like this trailer was advertising the haunted...
Where the fuck does the laboratory come in...
In this school?
I guess it's a lab...
Like for science in school?
But...
This was like one of the things...
Like what...
Like the whole theme was...
Haunted school in Ocean Park.
Yeah.
My parents wouldn't let me go to Ocean Park during Halloween...
Because that's where like...
That's where the...
Adult scary stuff is.
Like Disney...
Hong Kong Disneyland...
Was for the kiddie Halloween experience.
And then...
Uh...
Ocean Park was for...
The adults.
But that's a lie.
Okay, wait.
No.
That's...
That's a lie.
Because one time...
Hong Kong Disneyland went fucking hard.
Because I saw like a video about it.
Like Disneyland...
Hong Kong Disneyland haunted house.
They went really hard...
In one of their haunted houses.
It was actually like...
Pretty crazy.
It was called like...
The Maze of Nightmare.
I'll show you guys.
They did this in Hong Kong Disneyland.
It was crazy.
I was like...
I saw...
I saw like...
The trailer for it.
And...
Um...
I saw the trailer for it.
And like...
One of the haunted houses...
Were like...
I was like...
A kid should not...
I don't think a child...
Would be okay.
I...
This was like...
This was seven years ago.
But it's called...
Maze of Nightmares...
At Hong Kong Disneyland.
You might be like...
This is not so bad.
But like...
Um...
Oh, it's not so bad.
Look, there's the Monster Inc.
people here.
See?
The children love seeing that.
But then...
Like...
And you're like...
Okay, that's fine.
It's just a...
It's just the Mad Hatter.
That's all right.
But then...
I saw this.
And I was like...
That's not all right.
I was like...
That's not...
I saw that.
And then you're like...
Okay.
And so...
I saw like...
Somebody going through...
That is...
Much...
Less...
All right.
I feel like...
If a child saw...
When a child sees that...
If he's like...
Holy fuck.
I need...
Oh man.
I need to...
See where...
Okay.
Is it this one?
I think it's this one.
Okay.
Hey, Keef.
All right.
Okay.
So like...
Let me...
Let's watch...
Let's go through this.
Yeah.
But when you're a child...
Going through this...
It's like...
Oh wait.
Dude, what's a higher quality video than this?
But we'll...
Let's look at Keef's video.
I mean...
This just looks really cool.
This was a...
This was a Disneyland...
Haunted house...
Maze.
But like...
I remember there was one...
Where like...
I saw someone get...
Like...
You see someone get murdered.
Basically.
And there's...
Faciliator.
But for...
That guy.
Where is it?
It was like...
Pretty creepy.
Oh my god.
It's like...
Pretty creepy.
But I'm trying to like...
Remember...
What scene it was.
Jesus.
Jesus...
Ah.
I...
That's not okay.
That's...
That's okay.
That...
Oh yeah, that was not, that's not, that's not.
Oh here, this one was creepy.
Not this one, but that's creepy.
But this room, this room.
I saw an HD video of this, and this one was really, I didn't, this one was creepy.
I won't say like, it's scary, but like, this one is creepy.
I find it creepy, because he's like, trapped in a room, of beheaded, animals.
Like, there's Bambi, like, an actual insane Mad Hatter, because you can see Bambi's in there, by the way.
There's, there's, imagine, you're a kid, and you saw Bubba, a beheaded Bambi.
He's like, I think he's mad, and he's like, asking, he's like, asking the kids, do you want it?
You, listen, say yum, ta.
Ha ha ha ha.
Uh oh.
Oh no, oh no, he's gonna, he's approaching the child.
Oh my god, I told you, the child's running away.
Oh my god, the child, I told you, he preached, the child ran away.
I told you, if I was a child, I'd be so freaked out.
I, I, I, I, oh my god, it's really, the killer is escaping, and CT containment preach.
Oh my god, he actually wanted to grab the child.
Oh my god, if
you don't listen, he's gonna cut me.
Oh,
we offer an interactive experience.
Like, I'm gonna cut your head.
Bro, that jump scare.
What's next after that?
I mean, it's pretty cool.
It's pretty cool.
I just thought, like, when I saw that, I was like, I was like, bro, children?
I, I, it is cool.
But for kids, children do not think it's cool.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure the children did not think that was cool.
Oh yeah, there was this, wait.
What is this?
Um, it should not be there.
Wait, there's more.
There's more videos I can show you guys.
Uh, cause like, this one was like, Hong Kong, Halloween, Disneyland.
Halloween and Hong Kong, Disneyland was like, went like, so hardcore.
Is it this?
Oh yeah, here, you get to be like, up close and personal.
Like, Pennywise?
Like, if I saw this, I'm...
That is not okay.
Oh my god, he's like, help me, please.
Help me.
Run away, Padukio!
Someone help me!
He's like, are you all happy?
And then Pinocchio's literally...
Okay, you guys don't understand what they're saying.
Some of you guys might not understand.
But Pinocchio is literally like, begging for his life right now.
It's like, he's like,
he's literally begging for his life.
I can feel it in my soul.
The fact that...
This is like, official Disney, by the way.
This is not parody or anything.
Like, this is real...
A real Disney Pinocchio.
Oh, another new studio.
Oh, it's the screamer!
Trying to suck your...
Suck your screams.
What's this?
Oh, he's gonna kill him!
Oh my god!
He's begging for his life!
And you're all just filming it!
Like, wait!
I know like, Japan...
Disneyland Japan during Halloween...
No, it's like...
No!
Universal Halloween in Japan is pretty hardcore too.
What I've...
What I saw.
I remember seeing like, really hardcore shit in...
Um...
For it.
But yeah!
No, I thought it was a...
When I remember when I first saw like, the...
Uh...
Hong Kong Disneyland...
Haunted house stuff.
I was like, holy...
Fuck!
That's scary.
That's so scary.
Um...
Alright, sorry.
Enough amusement park shit.
That's...
That's actually...
Is there...
What else can we do?
In Hong Kong?
Other than ocean parking...
I wanna go to Mong Kok.
That's like, one of my favorite places to go.
Whenever I'm there.
For anyone that's never been there.
It's like...
It's like, basically where you can buy...
Like...
Um...
There's like, lots of stuff you can buy.
There's like, uh...
Lots of food.
And like, uh...
Merch.
And like, cute stuff.
And everything.
Like, um...
The official hot...
Like, a lot of like...
Official...
Uh...
Official, uh...
Buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh.
Toy Studios are in Mong Kok too.
Alright, let's look.
Yeah, oh this brings back memories.
Like the little bamboo pillars there when you walk down.
And then the yellow minibuses and the red taxis.
I'm gonna take a new bus.
Actually... Taxis are pretty cheap though.
Like in Hong Kong.
Or I just take the... Actually I should just take...
The MTR.
What am I saying?
I should just take the metro.
I need to buy an octopus card though.
I don't have an octopus card anymore.
Buh buh buh buh.
All that brings back...
Oh, are they now... Are they now expensive?
MTR.
Metro.
And it is Nathan Road.
Oh yeah!
You can now put it in your apple wallet.
I forgot about that.
I don't remember what it's called.
There was like Mong Kok.
There was a place in Mong Kok.
Where it's like...
Where it's mostly like...
Anime figures and stuff.
Maybe I'll go there when my Nendoroid comes out.
So I can see and be like...
There's me!
Oh look, foot palace.
Oh there's the ladies market.
This is like very...
This is a very touristy spot though.
Right here.
I...
I normally don't go through this area.
Because tourists love...
Love going through this area.
So like there's a lot of overpriced stuff.
Because of it.
I mean it's like a great experience.
It's a great experience though.
If you've never been here.
But like...
Um...
A lot of tourists love going here.
So a lot of...
There's like...
A lot of places here.
It's like...
You gotta haggle.
Yeah.
You have to haggle for it.
And there's like...
It's more so for...
It's like a...
More so for tourists though.
Yeah.
Alright.
What is it?
Oh there's the...
Haha!
The night mask!
Do they go down to that?
Does anyone know what that place is called?
The one...
The...
Oh I love...
Oh my god.
It looks so good.
That looks so good though.
Where are the ladies?
Does anyone know what that place is called in Mongkok?
The...
The one where...
You can buy anime figures and stuff?
Oh this is the sneaker area.
This is the sneaker street.
Everything in this street...
I remember this street.
But...
Everything...
Oh is this Sinocente?
Sinocente?
Everything on this street is just...
Sport related stuff.
So like...
It's all...
It's called...
It's the...
I don't know what it's called.
But I call it sneaker street.
It's just shoes.
It's mostly like running shoes.
I remember this place.
I love Mongkok though.
Come buy tea.
All right.
And this is...
Ying...
Ying Chong street.
All right.
Is this Sinocenter?
Sinocenter?
Sinocenter Hong Kong.
Is there a little walking tour of it?
Oh, there it is.
Discover.
Here.
Oh, I love this place!
Is it this place?
Oh, by the way.
This is like a little...
This is the MTR area.
Always remember to be on the right hand...
Is it right hand side?
Always remember to be on the right hand side.
Because...
It's...
Okay.
I found out in different places, it's different direction.
cause in Hong Kong, we always have to be on the right side.
So, you can see that everyone's always on the right side.
I know that...
Like people in NA don't know about this rule.
But like...
When you're on the right side, if you're not in the rush...
And then on the left side, if you're on the rush...
You can walk up the stuff.
But like...
But like, I found out the different countries it's different.
But not NA people don't care in NA.
I know, like, I think Japan was left, right?
I think Japan is, like, if you're not in a rush, you go on the left side.
Yeah.
Or something.
It was, like, in Japan or, like, somewhere else.
I don't remember.
But, like, because I remember I was trying to stand on the right side, and then I realized, oh, wait, everyone's on the left.
And then I was like, oopsie.
Yeah.
So this is the MTR, metro station.
It's very clean.
I like it.
Because I remember when I was first in New York City, I was like, oh, they have a metro subway just like in Hong Kong.
It was not the best experience.
Because I would think, like, oh, yeah, maybe it's just like the one in Hong Kong.
Yeah, it was not.
It just smelled like piss.
It really just smelled like piss.
In New York City.
Oh, you know what I'm really looking forward to?
I think it's the same in Japan, but they, um, in Hong Kong, they always do these little promotion things in 7-Eleven.
I wonder what the promotions are now.
I think my favorite one was the Sanrio and the Disney one.
I don't know.
People in Hong Kong might remember it, but it's the little metallic, the plastic, little plastic figures at 7-Eleven at that time.
And it was to celebrate Hong Kong Disneyland.
And everyone was fucking obsessed about it in Hong Kong at 7-Eleven.
I was, I was obsessed with it.
Wait, this is the metro station.
And then, take me to Sino Center.
Sino Center?
I don't remember what it's called.
Oh, here.
This is the classic area.
There's a Chikawa promotion right now.
Oh, Chikawa.
Go in.
Oh, here it is.
I love this.
I used to go to this place all the time.
Basically, there's like, it's just all, it's like, figures.
I would buy my phone cases here, too.
I would buy, like, they have some really cute phone cases.
And, um, like, uh, accessories for your phone.
I loved exploring here.
Every time I get to go to Hong Kong.
Oh my god, they have fucking crane machines now?
Yeah, it's the Tech, Anime, and Computer Center.
It has it all.
I didn't buy so many things here.
There's also, like, Japanese magazines and stuff.
And cards, too.
This is where I bought my Italia cards.
And then sold some of them to, like, NA people.
I would say it's, like, Hong Kong, Akyabara.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
They have, oh, they have these.
They have, oh my god.
That, this is new.
I've never seen this before.
Hot Toys.
I love Hot Toys.
For those who don't, they have, the Hot Toys Studio is actually here.
Um.
The Hot Toys, uh, uh, office is here.
In Mong Kok.
I don't know, did they ever move?
Because I used to go to the Hot Toys, um, I used to go to the Hot Toys, uh, office to get their stuff.
Yeah, it's the secret base.
I have several figures from them when I used to live in Hong Kong.
I have the, I have the low-key one.
I have low-key and one of the Iron Man's.
And then I don't remember what else I have.
Of course there's Pop Mart in Hong Kong.
Majority of the famous Pop Mart, um, not majority, but a lot of the really popular Pop Mart figures, come from Hong Kong Illustrators.
The boo-boo was designed by Hong Kong Illustrator.
It's okay, I don't care.
I don't care about the boo-boos.
Well, usually it's all, they usually, okay, you will know when it's a fake store.
Because the, the real ones, you, because like, majority of the stores here, back then when I was here, were like, legit.
Were like, legit stores.
They don't sell, like, bootlegs.
But you would know if it's a bootleg store.
Yeah!
Maybe I want to come over here when my Nendoroid comes out.
Check me like, that's me!
Also, I used to be really good at spotting bootlegs.
But like, I don't know anymore.
Oh my god, look at all this Gundam stuff.
Yeah, and they're really easy.
I don't know if they got better or not.
So I can't, I can't tell.
And then you could do like, this gacha post.
Do they still have the R18 store here?
Does anyone, wait, guys.
If you're, if you know, you know.
But I remember, my, my dad accidentally let me go into an R18 store.
There's only one.
There's only one in this mall.
And like, I accidentally went there.
Because, um, because, and I was with my dad.
And my dad did not know.
And, wait, many?
Okay, I just knew that one.
Because I was trying to find a very important figure.
And, it's like, yeah, it's in the corner.
And I went in.
And then I, then my dad went in with me.
And then I saw a naked woman.
And then my dad like, pulled me out.
I saw, I saw like those, like a photo card of a naked woman.
and my dad pulled me out.
I just know the one.
I don't know if there's more than one.
Little did he know.
He was like, he was like, wait, saw la.
Oh, Shin-chan.
Susan.
Oh my gosh.
You're so cute.
I love these.
I would spend so much time here.
Just looking through everything.
This is my favorite, favorite thing to do.
Whenever, I would like, beg to go to Mong Kok.
Because it's like, my favorite place to go.
This was literally like, my, I would use my red pocket money for this place.
one time, my dad, one time for my birthday, my dad was like, what do you want for your birthday?
And I was like, I want to go to Mong Kok.
And then, and then like, my dad would just take me here and then let me be like, okay, your budget is X amount of money.
And then I just like, walked around to spend like, X amount of money around here.
And then I would also spend my red pocket money here too.
Like, after Chinese New Year, I would like, come here, and just spend my money.
That's why I had, I had so many figures.
Oh, buy three, get one, get one, buy three, get one for three, free.
Oh my God, did you hear that?
Buy three, get one for free.
Oh, what a deal.
What you call it?
We're react channel now.
Wait, is that, wait, is that, wait a minute.
Wait, I want that.
This better still be there when I'm there.
Is that sausage?
Bro, I want, I want a key chain of, oh my God.
Is that a sausage?
Bro, that's a key chain of a sausage.
I want that.
Always has.
I too.
Oh my God, this is like, okay, this is actually nostalgia.
This is, that's when you know, this is serious.
Okay, I love these.
These ones are the actual, legit, serious figure stores.
Where like, they, they're literally here to hold pre-orders.
This is like a legitimately, legit business.
But I love these ones because, you go there only to pre-order.
So that's why you see all these paper stuff.
So like, and then you pre-order, yeah, you pre-order here.
You see all these boxes, they're all pre-orders.
So you go here for the latest figure, and then you go to them to pre-order.
Because these are like, cheaper too, because you don't have to pay for shipping at all.
So like, because like, they handle all this shit.
Like, you don't have to pay for shipping and it usually is cheaper than ordering online on the store.
So yeah, this is a serious business.
So every time I want like, a figure I really, really want, I would just like, go to these stores for just pre-order.
Yeah.
Yeah, no sightseeing.
You know what you want.
You're not here to window shop.
You're here on a mission.
Yeah, and yeah, he has like a, you basically, you go up to him for, for all the pre-order stuff.
You go pre-order and leave, exactly.
You're just not here for sightseeing.
But sightseeing in this best part of shopping.
Unless you're here for serious business.
Oh my god, look at everything.
It's so cute.
Jimmy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, also there's like, I think it's like three floors.
Three or four floors.
I'm not, I don't remember that much.
It's been so long.
Oh.
Oh my god, the crane machines are new though.
I don't remember the crane machines.
Oh my god, is that Nekopara?
the zoom in!
That guy fucking zoomed in on that.
That's crazy.
Yes.
That's actually crazy.
Real sly.
He had not done a single zoom in before, by the way.
Yes, I haven't seen this guy do any zoom ins until now.
Wow.
Let's see.
It's mostly just, I think, I might, oh, I love this, I love, that's, I love this one.
This is one of my favorite, uh, uh, Resident figure, uh, series.
By the way, it's really silly, this one, this tiger one, because like, in his figures, they show his balls.
If you know this toy series, his, his, his feature, is that, his balls are showing.
His,
you can buy it at Pop Mart.
Why is he, why is he zoom, he's zooming at all, he's zooming at all the ladies.
Oh, hey, there's a minion.
Of course, he zooms in.
That's funny.
That's really funny, that he zooms in on all the, all the ladies.
It was on Goak.
No, no, it was definitely not.
It was on the, what was it?
Re, was it, is it called ReZero?
Or Rem, right?
Oh my god, there's an actual, oh, there's an actual bookstore.
It was on Rem.
I saw it.
I know, I know what I, I know what you are.
Oh, and then these are all for the cards.
You can get all the cards here.
It's literally just cards.
And there's more figures.
And there's Gundam.
They have like a custom, custom, garage kit one, garage kit store too.
I know they have a garage kit store as well.
When I was there.
I don't know if it's still there though.
Oh, these are the, the mini figures.
The mini blind boxes.
Wait, is that, what's the store to my left?
Is that where the item is?
Oh yeah, that, you might not see it, but I saw the item store.
I, I,
I see what you are on the left.
I, I see you.
What's this?
Oh, these are for the, IRL items.
I, I, I know what you are.
I, I like how, I like how you do the slow pan for it.
In this point?
I don't, I don't know what In this point is.
Maybe, I'm gonna look that up.
Oh, look, if his video is still, up, my, my live stream will still be up, I believe.
Alright, this is, this would be a fun place to come back to.
I'm there, thank you for the raid, thank you, thank you.
Sorry, I know like we spent, oh my god, nostalgia.
This bag right here, nostalgia, right here, the classic.
And, that was Cino Center.
This was my go-to, uh, my go-to place when I went, whenever I want to shop for, like, figures and stuff, or, like, uh, cute things.
Was it, what was it, Ena's?
What is it called?
The newer place that people go to now?
Uh, because I never heard of that.
What was it called?
Ena, uh, uh,
Ena's Point?
I never heard of, I never heard of that place before.
Ena's Point, Hong Kong, the best and cheapest Hong Kong display.
I don't think I've been here before.
Is this new?
Ba-dum!
BOMB!
Um, holy shit.
Holy, that's so intense.
What the fuck is this Google Map shit?
This is where to go.
It's so epic.
It's a very serious business, guys.
Now there's a sound aside in a world.
Alright.
I've never been to this place before.
Okay, I'm sorry.
I'm not gonna listen to that.
This is new.
Yeah, this is new.
I've never been to an inn's place before.
This is new for me.
Of course!
Oh my god.
Oh, that's cute.
It's old?
I've never been to inn's place.
For, uh...
For shopping, for figures.
I usually would be at Sina Center.
But to be fair, that was like more than 10 plus years ago for me.
You find tons of Cinemoro merch?
Careful.
Oh my god, there's Lego.
I've been like...
Okay, not gonna lie.
Not gonna lie.
I've been watching so many Lego shorts lately.
It's so...
Like...
It's just so like...
Interesting.
It's very interesting.
Like the Lego stuff.
Oh my god, look at all the...
There are so many...
So many posters.
All right.
Let's look at...
Food in Hong Kong.
All right.
This is...
Best Hong Kong street food.
All right.
Let's judge this.
The first... okay, it's one out.
Oh my god, I love these noodles.
Oh my god.
This noodles with...
These noodles with la chuchun, so good.
That shit is so fucking good.
You're reacting to it now.
It's so late for this.
Is that bola, yo?
We'll eat everything from a street food stall where the pyromaniac chef attracts hundreds of hungry people.
Alright.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Okay, I love these types of fish.
I don't- I don't care.
Show me the food.
Oh my god.
I remember taking, like, the ship tours on this.
Where the seats can go back or forth.
Cause, like, back then...
Um...
This was, like, sort of the only way to, like, go back and forth.
Cause there was no station back then that goes there.
Hello, HSBC Bank.
I like how- It was, like, the first food that comes to mind.
There's HSBC Bank.
Yeah, this place is buzzing.
It's packed.
I love the atmosphere.
This...
I mean, you know you're in Hong Kong when you're here.
Here?
Hello!
Whoa!
What are you making?
Oh man, this is so incredible to see.
I mean, this is...
really...
behind the scenes.
Chen Fun?
That's not Chen Fun.
That's...
Is that...
Hakao?
What is that?
Just their experience.
I know it's dim sum, but, like, what you...
The Chinese cleaver and just spreads it out into a perfect circular...
What the...
What dim sum is this?
Or dim sum has this?
Is that Hakao?
It looks like Hakao.
And they're making...
In the process of making Hakao, which are the...
Yeah!
You can't revoke my Hong Kong card!
I was able to tell it was Hakao.
I...
I was like...
Yeah!
One point!
To me!
I...
I was right!
I'm sorry.
I was so happy.
I...
I was like...
I was right!
Oh!
Um...
Fuck!
Ah!
Um...
It's...
It's one of the fun.
I...
Ah!
I don't remember what is it called in Cantonese cause I don't like the...
The cha...
Like what is it?
The chives the little- The garlic.
It's not garlic, the- The- The thing in the meat.
I don't like it.
It's one of the chan fuan .
Because...
And I- I don't- But...
But...
Sorry...
But I don't...
aerto chan fuan Is it aception chan fuan?
Yeah, I don't like the chive in it.
I'm not a fan of the chive in it, is true...
The taste for it is like, not my favorite.
It has, like, a... was it the bamboo sprout?
Is it bamboo sprout?
I don't know.
I don't think it's chat, but it's, like, one thing that makes it, like, taste a little spicy.
Oh my god, this is, like, memories.
It's not chat.
The bitter taste.
Yeah, the bitter... it's a slightly bitter, spicy taste.
The bean curd roll?
Oh, this one.
Oh, this one, I love it, yes.
I don't like this.
Oh, uh, that's alright.
So when you hold it, you hold it at the side.
Oh, I love... I love the little sponge cake.
That's one of my favorites.
Some dim sum.
You gotta be a little bit aggressive, but I think that's part of the experience.
That's what makes it.
I travel for food.
Oh, man, so good.
We saw the whole process of them making...
Kakao!
That's my favorite.
Shrimp and pork.
And bamboo shoots.
That's my favorite.
Yeah, with ...
Yeah, with ....
And then there's... Oh, he has  next to him.
To me, it brings back so many memories.
Oh my god, um, um, .
Oh, my guy.
Oh, that looks so good.
That looks good.
Sticky rice.
It's like classic.
What the fuck?
Where are they?
This shit's fancy.
What the fuck?
I'm so used to eating, like, Hong Kong, like, you know, like, the street restaurants and stuff.
I was like, what the fuck?
This place looks fucking fancy.
Yeah, this shit is...
It's like, it's so different.
That shit is expensive.
That's like fucking Michelin.
Are we...
Are we on Hong Kong Island?
Still in precision, so fast.
Oh, my God.
They're wearing, like, chef hats and everything.
The pork.
You see some fat in there.
You see some shrimp in there.
And he takes kind of like a mixture of it with a little...
From $30 to $300.
Oh, is this...
Oh, my God.
You know that this is expensive.
Expensive.
They have this shit.
This shit is so expensive.
Underneath is the diced chicken with mushrooms.
I don't remember...
I don't know what they are, but I know that shit is expensive.
Because, like, my mom makes me eat one if they order it.
Because they'd be like, we spent lots of money for this.
You know, okay.
I don't know if anyone's parents are like this.
But, like, whenever my parents...
Like, whenever my family order really expensive shit, They forced me to eat it.
Because they're like, we spent a lot of money on this.
You have to eat it.
Even if I don't like it.
Oh, my God.
That shit looks good, though.
Sumai.
This is fancy fucking Sumai.
It looks like this, but the top part is like...
Has like, like, the little, the eggs on top.
Like the, like, the little fish eggs.
But that shit looks fucking fancy.
With a carrot on the bottom?
Holy shit.
What the fuck is on top of that?
This is in your mouth.
Or is it crab eggs?
I don't know.
Incredible.
Legendary.
Okay, now we're...
This is...
Okay.
This looks good, though.
Oh, my God.
There's live crab.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Oh, that looks good.
Oh, it's this dish.
I know this dish.
I know this.
Yeah, you...
If you guys didn't know, you have to boil crabs and lobsters, like crustaceans alive for the best taste.
Which is pretty fucked up.
But, like, um...
That's, like, apparently, like, how you're supposed to cook them.
Because, like, the more alive they are when you boil them, the tastier it is.
What an incredible recipe.
So, oil goes in the...
Uh, dungeon, welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
The screams of pain adds flavor.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Scorches.
The flavor is fully released.
Then some chili goes in.
Then the crab goes in.
He artfully places that around, and it lets them walk.
Roar.
Yeah, don't make it quick to release something that makes it taste very bad.
Yeah.
So, like...
So, like, that's how they do it.
That's...
Oh.
I like it with...
That, too.
I like it with this.
Okay.
Oh, this looks so good.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, that...
Okay.
This is classic.
This is, like, a classic place to eat.
When you're, like, in these types of restaurants.
Because you know it's, like, all about the food.
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
The brisket.
You can see that.
I love going to these types of restaurants.
At the same time.
Yeah.
Like, they...
And then, like...
I remember my mom took me to one of these.
And then there is, like, they had, like, news articles of, like...
People being, like, wow!
Mr. Wah, they've won Hong Kong awards.
This place is...
Yeah, this is...
By the way, this is a Michelin star restaurant, by the way.
Local Hong Kong awards.
Yeah, I know, like...
Pictures all over the walls and awards.
This is literally a local Michelin star restaurant.
We also got a bonus of their brisket curry.
Oh?
Which I'm very excited about as well.
I think different parts of the brisket...
Oh, man.
That looks rich and thick and...
Oh.
That looks good.
Prince Edward Station!
For a quick tour to eat...
Iconic Hong Kong street foods.
Most of them on sticks.
Ah!
Okay, here we go.
Pull it out of the bag.
What the fuck is that?
Virginia seasoned it for us.
What is that?
That's a whole...
Yeah, whole...
It's a whole brick of tofu.
That tofu?
Oh my god.
It's...
You know, I thought...
I thought, you know...
When they're like, we're gonna go street food.
I thought like...
That he was gonna get the classic one.
Which was...
You know...
Sumai or...
Or gala yu dan.
Not tofu.
You know?
I feel like...
Sumai or gala yu dan.
Is like...
More classic.
Or...
Gai dan jai.
Really crispy.
And then really juicy on the inside.
Juicy and crumbly.
Almost cheesy.
This is classic.
But like...
My...
I feel like...
Um...
I...
I personally like the...
The yu...
Gala yu dan.
More.
Better.
There's a wet wipe.
I personally like the taste of...
Gala yu dan.
More.
Than the...
The stinky tofu.
Fried intestines?
Okay, excellent.
What's that?
He pokes it with a skewer.
Slices it off.
Wait, I know you've seen this one before.
Nice.
What is that?
Okay, soy sauce.
Yep.
Tangy sauce.
And then mustard.
Is that intestines?
Okay.
Oh, nice.
Oh, is that fried intestines?
I've never had this one before.
The mustard makes...
We have...
73.
Where's my garlic yu di Sony?
Did he leave?!
Thisot.
What the fuck is...?
I can't believe he left.
hiosa lige news has been a legendary one a Ummm perry since 1976.
Curry fish ball has two comments.
What do you mean?!
It's...
is Greek.
It'sing peak.
Open this up.
The famous legendary.
Hong Kong...
pretend to ding much...
And we also got it with the... the butter already sliced on the inside.
Nice.
This is so good.
I love Bolo.
I'm getting angry.
How dare you not eat my favorite classic Hong Kong food?
How dare you?
I can't believe it.
Oh!
Yay!
Okay, I'll eat redeemed.
I think it's like the most iconic strip food.
I told...
She said it too!
It's the most iconic strip...
I... SHE SAID IT TOO!
What?
Look at that.
Happiness is back.
It's like I'm there.
Maybe I don't need to take a vacation.
I can just... I can just watch these YouTube videos.
It's like I'm right there, right now.
Toki, please.
I'm living vicariously through these videos right now.
What the fuck?
What is this?
What?
Food, Marks, Coca-Cola?
And this place, they're very famous for their Hong Kong style clay pot rice.
But how are they able to crank out thousands...
Oh, clay pot!
K-pop?
A clay pot!
Oh, I love clay pot rice.
Somebody actually ordered me a rice cooker on his own.
...basket after basket full of the clay pots, and they only serve one size.
It's a personal pot size.
And so he's just putting one bowl of rice.
That's so good.
You get together some of the different conversions with chicken, with pork, ginger, and green onions as well.
Whoa, only 15 minutes?
Oh my god, this only takes 15 minutes to make.
He's not even measuring.
He just knows from experience how much water to put in.
Turn off the fires.
Oh my god, that's a lot of clay pots.
So that's a full rack, all 30 clay pots going at once, all the fires cranking.
That's so much heat radiating off of here.
It takes so much concentration and dedication.
It's almost like he's playing an instrument when he's lifting the wings.
That's so cool.
Oh my god.
Pie quite fine.
That's so good.
I'm gonna go to some of these places this guy is recommending.
Oh my god, I'm only not even halfway.
How long have I been watching this video of just food?
I'm sorry.
I couldn't help it.
It's literally just food.
I love these.
I love, I love this type of dish for fish.
This stuff, rather than being flaky, the grouper is flaky.
The thread print is more creamy and soft, I think.
But really, incredible...
I love these, I love, I love this type of dish.
Fish for fish.
This is like childhood.
For me, it's a childhood meal.
For me.
Like, I grew up with this type of, like, uh, how my parents would make fish for me.
Or, like, my grandparents.
What is it?
Oh, they actually have two locations.
One around the corner, one here.
But I think this one is the original one.
This is the spot.
This is a very popular place.
We had to wait a little while at the door, but we made it in pretty fast.
Lau-som-ki-noodle.
This is a legendary restaurant dating back to 1956.
It's three generations still in the family.
And they are most famous for their one-ton noodles.
Oh, wait, I've been here!
No, I've been here!
I remembered!
I know this place!
They still make their own noodles, and they still use the bamboo.
I've been here before!
You need the dough.
Ah, so it's fresh.
It's quality.
My parents took me here.
Yeah!
This one is the classic.
Just the egg noodles.
It's so good.
The noodles with the one-ton.
One-ton mean.
It's so good.
This is actually really, really good.
I miss that.
I've never eaten this one, though.
I just eat the one-ton mean.
All right.
Where are they?
Oh, this place!
One of the original boats, a sampan, and we're gonna enjoy another- Causeway Bay.
One of the original boats, a sampan, and we're gonna enjoy another seafood meal.
Causeway Bay is like a classic area.
Typhoon shelter.
This is like such a- It's a very classic tourist spot, I would say.
A lot of tourists come here.
This is absolutely incredible.
We've gotten dropped off in our own sampan.
And this is a taste of the traditional culture of fishing boat culture.
Wait, what?
I've never done this before.
And yet it's so traditional here.
Wait, I actually want to do this when I'm there.
That's so cool.
These were invented some of the dishes, uh, within these boats cooking for fishermen.
But that's so cool!
Yeah, if you guys didn't know, Hong Kong was originally a fisherman village.
Um, it was just a small village for- to fish.
And this is- That's so cool!
Basically, we have four early ethnic, like, clans in Hong Kong.
The Puntys and the Hakkas.
And then they took the farmable land.
So then the Tenkas and the Haklos- Oh, there's the- the burnt crab.
The Boiled Alive crab.
Oh, it's so pretty!
Christmas in Hong Kong is really, really pretty.
With the light decorations.
Oh!
And it just came out of the oven.
You can tell that they specialize in Chasu and that's one of the favorite things that you said.
Chasu?
Chasu!
Stalagmites and stalactites and they just- I look so juicy!
Oh my god!
I love Chasu!
Chasu!
Okay, you know what I just- I noticed?
I found out?
I didn't realize this.
But, um, a lot of like- I think like- I don't know if it's like how we prepare it.
Like how Hong Kong people prepare it.
But we love fatty meat.
Like, cause like, um, I was recommending some food to one of my friends.
Um, and my friend was like, ooh, I don't really like all this fat meat.
Um, I like prefer lean meat.
And I didn't know- I didn't realize that, like, we love fatty meat.
The flavor from it, yeah.
I like- Yeah, I didn't even realize that.
I can't tell the difference between- Um, I can't tell the difference between like fat meat and lean meat.
I just- If it tastes good, then it's good.
Yeah, exactly.
I was like, but the flavor though.
I was like, the flavor is so good though.
As long as it's good.
Oh my god.
Kobe.
The next LeBron James.
Like, holy shit.
He doesn't even have to look.
He literally just like- He literally was just like-
Muscle memory.
You know how to throw those meats.
That's how you know that- Oh my god.
That's how you know that man's a fucking pro.
That uncle's a pro.
Right there.
Is this- Oh, I'm guy?
I love- I love cold chicken.
That shit's my favorite.
Tatsu.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, that looks so good.
Oh, with the sauce too.
And the green- In the green, uh- In the green little plate.
Without eating roast goose.
That's so true.
We should love dark meat.
Are you ready for that reveal of the cross-section?
Oh.
With the crispy skin- Sweet plum sauce.
Yeah.
The juices are pouring out.
We love to eat any types of birds.
Like, uh- Like hot- Uh, not hot- For the- The cod.
Um.
Ah!
What is it called?
The- What was it?
The one- For the- The pigeons.
What are the pigeons one called again?
UGAP!
I love UGAP!
It dances on your tongue.
So good.
That's pigeon, by the way.
That's why you don't see pigeons around.
Because we eat them!
They're so good!
Nice and peon!
No, that's not the reason!
But just- By the way, you guys didn't know.
I'm joking, guys.
I'm joking.
But UGAP is really, really good.
Just so you guys know, I'm only- I'm joking, guys.
I'm- I'm joking.
I already believe in you.
Okay, but does anyone remember that fast food Hong Kong chain?
It's called- Because, like, that's actually one of my guilty pleasures to go there.
Like, I know it's like- Like, the really famous fast food Hong Kong chain, where you can get, like, Hong Kong food, but for fast food.
What is it called?
They're everywhere.
I don't remember what it's called, but I love- CAFE DECORA!
I love that place!
It's like our equivalent.
It's like basically, like, Hong Kong fast food.
Yes.
DAI...
Uh, CAFE DECORA.
Or is it- Is it DAI FAHLO?
I think there's two of them.
Isn't it CAFE DECORA or DAI FAHLO?
Heya.
DAI FAHLO- Uh, DAI- Is it DAI FAHLO?
Or DAI- Uh, DAI-GA- DAI-JAU- DAI-DAI-GA-MING- Yes, DAI-GA-L-T-HARA!
DAI-GA-L-T-HARA!
And CAFE DECORA.
That is my guilty pleasure.
I like both of them.
But- Both of them are like my favorite.
And, yeah.
Stay tuned for the first time.
DAI-GA-LO!
Yes!
There's like a little rivalry between them.
Some people don't tell them that they fight over me.
There's like a little rivalry between the two.
So it's like, you know how there used to be a rivalry between McDonald's versus Burger King?
That, for us, it's Daikalo versus Daifaiwo.
And people would argue which one is better.
There's like beef.
It's like, yeah, Coke versus Pepsi.
Which one was better for me?
Whichever one was closer.
Whichever one that's there, like conveniently close to me, I would go.
But I like that place because it's like fast food for Hong Kong food.
So it's like my guilty pleasure.
Food is food, exactly.
Food is food.
Wait, okay.
I want to show you guys...
Wait, I want to know if anyone made a video.
Okay, that's enough from this guy.
Okay.
I want to know if anyone made a video of this restaurant.
My favorite restaurant.
In...
In, uh...
In Hong Kong.
I'm so sad.
No one has made a video of my favorite restaurant.
I want to see if anyone made a video of my favorite restaurant called Tomato Club.
Hong Kong citizen here.
Why your research Hong Kong streams better than I showed speeds high stream...
Hong Kong stream.
I never heard of small boat ride.
I know!
That's so cool!
Was that cool?
That was so cool!
I didn't even realize that existed!
I didn't even know that existed!
I want to go there.
Autobot, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I get to eat in a boat?
In a tiny ass boat?
That shit's so cool.
I'm sad.
I can't believe they don't have my favorite restaurant in a video.
I can't believe it!
It's such a good restaurant!
It's one of my favorite places to eat!
Why don't they have it?
If you...
Okay, guys.
I'm advertising.
This is actually my favorite place.
Tomato Club, Hong Kong.
If you are in Hong Kong, you have to go to the tomato club.
I swear to God.
It's so good.
Okay.
Like, I'm not coping.
It's actually so good.
This is actually legitimately one of my favorite places.
Um...
Okay.
I tell...
Okay, I'll give you a reason why.
It's one of my favorite...
My favorite places.
I will show you guys why.
Let me find...
They only have their website.
They used to have two locations, but I think they only have one now.
Which makes me sad.
Because I know that...
They had one in Satine.
Um...
Uh...
It's where she was a boy.
No...
I'm so sad about it.
I think...
Um...
They used to have one in...
In Satine.
But I think it's...
Uh...
I think it's gone now.
Which makes me a little sad.
Because...
Okay, so...
Uh...
So...
This is Tomato Club.
And what makes Tomato Club so fucking good...
Is that...
The whole thing...
There's like...
Three...
The whole...
The soup base is literally tomato soup.
And like...
You can choose what noodles you want.
So it can be like any type of noodles you want.
And also, like...
The scrambled egg on top is what makes it really good too.
So it's like...
Um...
You can choose any noodles...
You can choose it to be spicy.
Um...
You can make it spicy or non-spicy.
And you put any...
Any toppings you want.
Um...
Any toppings you want too.
So like...
Yeah, as many toppings as you want.
And like, you customize it fully.
So this is one of my favorite places to go to.
We got one named... There's a new one?
No.
Don't say that about Tomato Club.
I grew up with Tomato Club.
Don't you dare say it's bitter or not.
Don't do that to me.
How dare you insult Tomato Club.
Respect your alters.
Tomato Club was there first.
She got protective of her tomato oshi.
I'm sorry.
PG, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm the number one.
You don't understand.
I would beg my dad to take me to Tomato Club, like, almost every day.
Like, I did not get tired of that shit.
I am Tomato Club's number one fan.
You know how, like, um, I remember what it's called.
What is it, Mr. Donut?
Like, Fuomoko did the whole, like, the whole, um, like, you're talking about their favorite, like, donut place.
This is, this is, this is my favorite place.
This is my favorite place.
Don't you dare take it away from me.
Like, no, no negotiate.
I am, I am, I am, I am Tomato Club's number one fan.
I am, I am, I am Tomato Club.
I turn into Gollum suddenly.
Definitely.
Yeah, but it's my favorite place to go eat.
It's like a childhood place for me because I would tell my dad to take me there almost every other day.
And then my dad was like, are you not tired of this place?
I was like, no.
I'm like, no.
I would die eating Tomito Club.
My dad would, like, beg me to, like, stop.
I don't want to go to Tomato Club.
It's like, I want to... I want to go to Tomato Club.
You dare question my everlasting love for Tomato Club?
Exactly.
Let's see.
Tomato Ching is better.
Seeing is better.
Rock, rock.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
When did they come up?
I bet you Tomato Club has been around longer.
Respect your elders.
All right.
I'm checking when they showed up.
Okay.
When did they show up?
Oh my God.
You can't feed them.
Okay.
Let's see.
When did... When did... When did... When did Tomato Seahang ever pop, like, showed up in this world?
Samsoi Po?
Is that Samsoi Po?
Okay.
Where is it?
I'm looking at the oldest review.
This shit just got real.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
gemacht lot is better.
comento club was there when the recipe was written. capturedlself.
Respect your elders.
All right.
Let's see.
What other places do I want?
Wait, Monkey.
What is Monkey Mountain called?
Monkey Mountain Hong Kong.
What is it actually called?
Oh, there it is.
Oh my god, they actually... Okay, Monkey Hill.
This place.
This is the place where I would always dry pass.
This is it.
Look, it's just a... Look, they're just sitting there.
This is Monkey Mountain.
Monkey Hill.
Oh my god.
It's literally Monkey Hill.
It's just monkeys everywhere.
And then my parents would be like, we don't want to go to Monkey Hill.
We don't... You don't want to see the monkeys in Monkey Hill.
And I always see them whenever we drive past Monkey Hill.
I'd be like, I want to... I want to meet the monkeys.
Yeah, they apparently like to steal stuff.
And like, they really like to steal stuff.
They're chill until they're not.
Look at her.
Oh my god.
Look, see?
They're okay.
Those children are okay with the monkeys.
Oh my god.
Oh
my god.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
They gave the monkey bubble tea?
They...
Oh my god.
Did he just give the
monkey...
He gave the monkey...
That's a crime.
I don't think you're allowed to do that.
What?
That's crazy.
Okay, that's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
Send him to monkey jail.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure you're not allowed to give the monkey bubble tea.
I'm fucking pretty sure.
What is this monkey doing with a cool kid?
What is this?
God.
They're out of control.
Oh, look at the monkey.
Oh my god.
There's so many monkeys.
Look at the monkeys.
Look at them.
Yeah, they're literally...
This is where I would drive past.
Right here.
I would be in my car or my taxi.
Like my red cab.
And then I'd see all these monkeys.
And then they'd all be in this parking lot too.
You're in the wrong neighborhood.
Welcome to Monkey Mountain.
You're so cute.
Look at all these monkeys.
So many monkeys.
One at a time, monkey.
One at a time.
Oh my god.
Just kidding.
This is where I want to go too.
I want to go to Monkey Mountain.
This is like...
Something I've wanted to go for the longest time.
Alright.
What else do we want to do?
Oh wait.
Are there maid cafes in Hong Kong?
I know there's a cat cafe.
I went to a cat cafe with my dad.
But...
Is there maid...
Is there one in Hong Kong?
Is there any...
Oh my god.
Wait.
Let's see.
Explore...
Wait.
Oh there is!
I know there is a...
Cat cafes.
I've never been to...
I've been to the...
The cat cafes there.
What is this?
Dreamy home?
I'm gonna mute this real quick.
Oh there is...
There's like little small ones.
Yeah.
There's like little tiny...
The small ones around.
Oh there's no like...
Like um...
Like the ones you see in Japan.
I've never been to the maid cafe in...
In Hong Kong though.
Wait.
Maid Planet?
Oh!
There's like an atom in maid cafe too.
Okay.
What about...
Oh my god.
Do they still have the...
Gutama cafe in Hong Kong?
Or is that gone?
Oh wait.
Is that...
Oh...
Oh my god.
This was nine years ago.
Okay.
I went to a...
I love...
Okay.
There was a...
This is one...
I don't know if this is the same one.
No.
It can't be.
But this is a...
This is a...
This is a Gutama...
A Gutama cafe in Hong Kong.
Please don't go to dreamy home.
I don't know what that is.
I...
Oh my god.
Look at that.
And he has a little bite.
Oh!
Yeah!
No!
They...
They win!
I am so happy.
It was the...
That was the core character.
They don't know.
They deserve that.
Oh my god.
The monster.
Like, someone said I didn't, I wouldn't see it.
And if I had to see it, if I had to suffer, I want everyone to suffer.
I want everyone to suffer, too.
I refuse to be the only one that saw this.
That demon!
I couldn't do this!
I could die!
I got an unexpected trauma.
I'll never be the same.
Alright, what else do I want to do when I'm there?
Hmm, oh my god, Kevin last night, that, apparently that, uh, the, the, it's like a pop-up cafe?
That sucks.
The, like, Utama stuff in Hong Kong are, like, pop-up cafes, but they're all so cute, though.
Which makes me sad, cuz I went to one, I, I went to one before, too.
Alright, what else?
What else is there to do, guys?
What else did I do when I'm there?
No, I, I'm never again.
I can't do hiking, guys.
I can't.
I'll, I'll be, go, I'll go missing.
I'll be, I'll, I won't return.
I'll be, I'll be, I'll be, I won't burn.
It's not a good idea!
Oh, there's a musicfest?
What's it called?
Oh, clock and flap, the lineup, oh, I don't know.
I'm not really a fan of music festivals to be fair.
It's just too many people in general.
I like looking from afar.
It's like because it reminds me of when I did like New Year Countdown in Hong Kong and there's so many people.
There's so many people.
And it was like... I felt like very claustrophobic there for like the New Year Countdown.
Thank you to the super chat.
Thank you.
And yeah, you want to go to see them.
But that's different.
That's different.
Let's see.
What else?
What do you need to do?
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
What is it called?
USA Gym?
Is that what it's called?
Jumping Gym USA?
I'm too... I'm too old for this.
But this was my childhood too.
Jumping Gym USA.
It was like... It was literally... It's like a... It's like an arcade, but for children.
But you'll also see grannies there playing the coin games.
You'll see... You'll see like all the grannies and stuff just sitting around the coin game...
The coin pusher games.
Because for them that was like... I guess like... Because it's like legal gambling type deal.
So... You'll see like all the grannies just doing the... Doing the little coin pushers.
And then like winning them for like... Winning like the mini prizes and stuff.
For like...
Because you can win like actual... You can win like actual...
Actual prizes.
Because my grandma went to Jumping Gym USA.
Which is like an arcade.
And like... She... She won something there.
And then she got a fucking rice cooker.
And then I was with my grandma.
I was like... Oh my god you won it!
And then she got the rice cooker.
And then...
So I was... I was like... Oh... Can I get the big pesky grandma?
And she's like... No, no, no.
You get something useful.
We get you something useful.
And then she got us the rice cooker.
And it was... It was that coin toss game.
It's a coin toss game.
It's not the rainbow one.
So there's several games where you toss a coin.
And... Um... It has to land on a spot.
So they have one with a rainbow.
But it was basically a coin toss game.
And there was a tiny square in the middle.
And my grandma landed it in the middle.
And she fucking picked a rice cooker.
So...
This is Jumping Gym USA.
Okay, we're no need to listen to them.
We just want to experience it.
Because we can make our own comments.
See, look.
So these are like...
These are the... These are the prizes.
They're gonna show you the prizes real quick.
And...
This is the generational beef.
So there's the cheap ones, right?
And then you turn to the right.
And then these are like...
The practical...
I mean, not practical.
These are like still the cheap ones still.
Don't worry.
When they turn to the left.
That's where the real prizes are.
That's when we get to the appliances.
There we go!
The appliances!
Yeah!
That's what I'm talking about!
That's where you get...
Oh, this has to be a newer one.
There's like...
Okay, so I want...
These are the newer ones.
Because...
They didn't have all these cranes though.
Back then.
Yeah, this is a newer one.
Jumping Gym USA.
Because I've never seen...
Okay, this is...
That's what I've seen a lot.
But...
The old ones...
Were like...
A lot different.
Oh my god!
Yeah, these are new.
I had a membership card, by the way.
I had a fucking membership card.
I was dedicated to the arcade life.
Let's see...
Maybe it's this one?
I wanna go to like an older one.
Yeah, I was like...
These are...
These...
The ones that that person went to...
Is like...
The newer ones.
Because the older ones are like...
A lot different.
I was like...
Where are my coin pushers?
Where are my grannies...
Sitting at the coin pusher machines?
Where are they?
There's so many...
Like...
There's so many crane games now.
There was not a lot of crane games back then.
When...
When I was there.
Oh my god!
Everyone's just doing the...
I don't wanna see the crane games!
Oh my god!
Stop showing me the crane games!
That's not my...
My authentic experience.
Oh my god!
It's literally all crane games.
It's...
That's how you know.
So many crane games.
What the fuck?
All I did there was coin pushers and...
And...
Throwing the coins at the fucking rainbow.
Where's my...
Where's my rainbow toss?
I'm angry.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
This is what I would...
This is what I spent most of my coins in.
Right here.
Right...
Okay.
Don't worry.
You'll see it soon.
This is...
This right here.
The whole majority of my coins.
And...
You toss your coin.
And it blasts and land on the rainbow.
And...
That's my favorite game.
That's all that you see.
But right here.
This was...
Peak Arcade.
The coin...
The grind.
This is where I was stuck in.
This was where I grinded my plushies.
I literally threw coins until I hit the rainbow.
This is it.
This simulates my brain.
This is where I would do.
Where like...
My parents would abandon me in...
In this area.
Cause I had my own card.
Um...
If like...
They were going shopping.
And the...
If we're at a mall...
Um...
And like...
They had a jumping gym USA.
My parents would abandon me.
I would...
They would...
Abandon me here.
And...
This was my daycare.
My...
My daycare.
And I spent most of it...
I spent most of it on the rainbow coin toss.
Uh...
And then they'll come back for me.
Um...
My daycare was this arcade.
With things to do in Hong Kong.
Yeah.
Cause I had my own like...
Membership card too.
Uh...
Cause they had...
They used to have a mascot.
And they were like...
The...
The Onis.
The red and blue Onis.
I think it was like...
The red and blue Onis or whatever.
And then like...
I think that's what they are.
I'm like...
Vague memories of it right now.
And like...
And I had a membership card.
And had so much fucking points in it.
And I never cashed out.
I...
Cause they expired too.
That was the worst part.
I kept hoarding them.
And then I hoarded them into expiring.
And I kept hoarding it again.
And then they'll expire again.
And I never cashed out.
I never cashed out all my points.
It was a very, very, very bad cycle.
What else to do?
I never learned.
I just kept hoarding it.
I just never learned.
All I did...
I kept thinking it would be different.
But I was wrong.
It was never different.
Oh yeah.
Since we're gonna be watching...
Since we're watching videos.
I wanted to show you guys.
I don't know.
I must have shown you guys already, right?
The new Jurassic Park ride in...
Shanghai Disneyland.
Oh wait.
No.
Sorry.
Not Shanghai.
Universal Studios in Beijing.
Jurassic Park owned by Disney.
By the way.
Sorry.
I meant Universal...
Beijing.
That ride is so scary.
Like I feel...
I don't know.
That ride is actually so fucking crazy.
Close in.
No.
For those who've never seen it.
So like...
This ride is like...
Different from...
It's like...
Holy shit.
That scared me.
Oh my god.
Cause it was like...
Why is it so quiet?
Okay.
But like...
Um...
Yeah, I know.
That scared me too guys.
Don't worry.
I was like...
Why is it not...
Why is there no sound?
Okay.
So what makes this ride...
Different...
Is that...
Look at this animatronic.
It's crazy.
This animatronic is actually crazy.
It's so close to...
It's so fucking close to you.
And like...
No, no.
This is like...
This is only in Beijing Universal Studios.
And then like...
Watch, watch.
It gets crazier.
So you're being chased by...
The Indom...
What is his name called?
Something's...
Indominate Rex?
Or some shit?
No, it gets a lot crazier.
It's so scary.
Like...
I don't think I could actually ride this.
I closed my eyes...
When I was riding the mummy in...
Uh...
The Universal Studios in the US.
Like...
I closed my eyes...
On that.
I closed my eyes for that ride...
And like...
Um...
And...
The Jurassic Park one.
And also the Harry Potter one too.
Like...
I was riding it with one of my friends.
And my friend like...
Kept like...
Slapping my legs.
Like...
Open your eyes!
During the Harry Potter one.
And I like...
I was like...
No!
It's like...
And then like...
The moment I opened my eyes...
Okay, this is...
Oh wait, this is here.
This is the freaky part.
It...
Chases you.
It actually chases you.
That shit is so scary!
You like...
Look at it!
And it chases you!
While you're fucking riding it!
Like...
And then the one time I opened my eyes...
Um...
The one time I opened my eyes...
It was when...
It was the...
The dragon part...
And like...
Where he like opened...
Like he was right in your face...
And breathing fire at you...
And like...
And I was just like...
How...
Why did you tell me to open my eyes?
What?
I thought that was...
That...
Really good.
What?
Oh my god!
Chinese Chris Pratt!
He can do anything.
Oh my god.
He is so talented.
He's so talented.
He really is in everything.
But yeah, no, I thought the...
But yeah, I won't spoil you guys this, but this part is actually the scariest for me.
This part?
Where it, like, comes after you and everything?
That shit is crazy.
And that... that red is freaking crazy.
Yeah.
That's so cool.
I know.
It's pretty cool, but that also scares me a lot.
Oh, just received an email from Grissmire.
Yay!
I'm happy.
It's gonna be shifted soon.
Uh, Sushi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh, let's see.
What else to do?
10 places to visit.
Okay, there is, like... okay.
There is, like, several malls I want to go to, though.
That I missed.
Uh.
Alright.
Let's see.
Harbor City.
Oh my god.
Harbor City is so fun to explore.
I love going around Harbor City.
Because, like, it's such, like, there's so many things you can do.
I like Harbor City.
Um.
I don't know.
I actually like Harbor City.
I, I, I, I, I, I like Harbor City.
I know some people are like, eh.
Um, but I like Harbor City because there's always, like, a lot of places to explore in Harbor City.
And they have really nice decorations and stuff there.
And, like, I always like seeing, like, the mall, the new shops that are here, there.
Yeah.
It's a really nice mall, Harbor City.
It's so pretty, too.
What about this?
I Square.
I know I Square.
Oh, yeah, I know I Square because I know this place.
I remember this place.
This place is, you see this area everywhere.
Is it kind of dead now?
Wait, why is it dead?
I've been to I Square a lot back then.
I only go to Harbor City in the years.
Okay, Harbor City has really good air con.
Yeah, I know.
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
I have C.
Central, the two international finance towers cast their long shadows...
Oh, my God, I have C.
Ma.
...street brands to choose from, including Celine.
If you look charming...
Oh, my God.
Is this person, like, okay?
Like, what is this...
What is this recording footage?
Is he, like, having a stroke while recording this?
Like, like, everything else was okay.
Camera man is shaking.
Oh, there's Causeway Bay, Ma.
Like, this is all right.
They're too excited.
They were really excited, but I have seen Ma.
He's being chased right now.
Is page one still around, or did they go bankrupt?
Total of 14 floors, as well as two basement levels...
Page one was, like, the local...
The bookstore place.
...connecting floors that are home to 230 shops, in addition to a cinema, and an excellent selection of restaurants, cafes, and fast food eateries.
Noooo!
Page one is gone!
Awwww!
For those who don't know, I used to...
I went to page one a lot, back then, growing up, and my favorite thing to do at page one, because it was, like, a bookstore.
Like, it was, like, a bookstore where you can get, like, English books and international books and everything.
And the best part about page one, um, is that they can, like, they'll, they'll, like, bind your books for free, so...
They'll, like, um, they'll put, like, um...
Like, if you buy a book, uh, they, like, um, put, like, a cup, like, uh, what's a lamp?
They'll laminate your books for free, basically.
Especially if it's hardcover.
That was, like, the best part about page one.
Yeah, the, so, like, if I want to laminate my books and stuff.
Okay, these were the malls I really wanted to go.
Because, like, I haven't been to, like, I haven't been to, like, uh, a big-ass mall in a long time.
Yeah.
Wait, that's really cool?
Well, you can't do that anymore.
It's gone now.
Page one is gone!
I'm so sad!
Can't believe it's gone!
That's a nice place.
Oh, I love IFC.
IFC at Central.
Oh, my God, he's walking around IFC.
Okay, let's watch him walk around.
It's like I'm there.
It's a really nice mall, too.
It's a very big and nice mall.
Oh, my God.
And he's not, like...
And he's not being chased while filming it, too.
How fancy this mall is.
What was that?
What was that supermarket?
That everyone would go to?
The fancy supermarket?
My mom would sometimes go to the fancy supermarket to buy the Onigiris and stuff for me.
It's here.
It's in IFC.
Is it City Super?
Is it?
I don't remember.
My mom would go there to buy the Onigiris.
It's in IFC, though.
Such a fancy mall.
Is this?
Oh, it is.
It is City Super.
Yeah.
That's also where she got her Fiji water.
I remember when I used to drink in Watson Sea.
Watson Sea.
Do they still sell that?
Does anyone remember Watson water?
The green bottle?
The green water bottle?
And then later on, my mom was like, No!
It's Fiji time.
We are a Fiji family now.
We are...
Yeah.
I used to drink...
I used to drink Watson Sea.
And then my mom was like...
One day, my mom was like, We are a Fiji water family.
And then one day, we couldn't drink Watson Sea.
And that was the day we became a Fiji water family.
And she would buy Fiji water at City Super.
Number one Fiji pen.
We're like, We can afford this now.
And we're not a Watson Sea family anymore.
Because, like, my mom was like, We are...
We can afford Fiji water.
And Fiji water is better.
Meep!
Thank you for the five gift of chips!
Thank you!
We went up the tax bracket.
I love exploring Mars.
It's such a fun time.
I just like going...
I just like walking around Mars.
Yay!
Oh my god, they have a McDonald's.
They have everything!
Even a McDonald's!
McDonald's!
There's not a lot of people here.
I don't know if it's just like...
Maybe it's the time of day?
This was a year ago.
Yeah, window shopping is so fun.
Oh my god, Chanel.
Oh, we are...
They're at the district where it's just brands.
They're like Celine, Louis Vuitton, Chanel.
Wait, why is there a Shake Shack above all of that?
There's like...
Like, you can see all these like high-class...
You can see Louis Vuitton right there.
And then on the top floor is a Shake Shack.
Like...
The Shake Shack reigns supreme.
Yeah, the Shake Shack is in the price here.
It's bougie.
It's...
Oh, if you guys didn't know this.
Okay.
Let me show you.
For those who don't know, I talked about this before.
But Spaghetti House...
Is like...
Fancy.
Fancy here.
The Spaghetti House.
Also, Pizza Hut too.
This is like...
Not fancy, but like you don't expect like Spaghetti House to be like a nice place to...
Like...
Like a...
Like a nice place to eat...
Spaghetti House and Pizza...
Oh, Pizza Hut in Hong Kong.
Pizza Hut is like...
Low-key...
Like...
Upper-middle-class.
I wish I was joking.
Yeah.
And it's like...
The decorations are so nice.
Let's see.
Let me see if I can find a video.
Yeah.
Pizza Hut is a sit-down restaurant in Hong Kong.
I think it's also in like...
In like...
Other places in China too.
I'm pretty sure.
There we go.
Watch this very shaky video from 16 years ago.
To this upscale restaurant.
What is it?
It's Pizza Hut.
I'm getting
over a...
Hong Kong.
I've been to the...
I know this Pizza Hut!
Wait a minute!
I know this...
I know that exact interior design.
And...
I've actually been to that exact Pizza Hut.
Guys.
It's crazy.
Oh my god.
Right here.
Look at this Pizza Hut.
It's so fancy.
This is a Pizza Hut, by the way.
I remember this place.
I need at this Pizza Hut.
Oh my god.
Share a slice of life.
Pizza Hut.
Oh.
Look at that.
Oh my god.
You even see a picture of the chef from Pizza Hut.
Yeah.
It's...
It's actually...
It's actually really neat.
I thought it was really neat.
Yeah.
That shit.
It's Mr. Pizza.
Oh my god.
It's Mr. Pizza from Pizza Hut.
That's him.
But if you're going to be in Hong Kong, you got to try it out Pizza Hut, guys.
I swear to god.
It's...
It's like a whole new world.
It's John Pizza Hut.
Alright.
Let's see.
Wait.
I want to see if they have this.
Anyone has a...
Oh here.
There's Secret Base.
I'll give you guys a tour.
For those who don't know.
Oh my god.
Really?
Okay.
You want to see something really cool?
Secret Base is so...
I've been here.
In Secret Base.
I love it.
It's so cool.
Yo.
Shout out to Ryan.
Hey.
Justin.
What is the darn thing?
Well, it's basically a massive showroom for Hot Toys.
It's their flagship store.
Now I...
So this is like where you get...
You pre-order like Hot Toys stuff too.
They don't actually sell much yet.
They do sell a couple of bits and pieces.
But for the most part, it's for pre-orders.
You come in...
Yeah.
I usually go here for pre-orders for Hot Toys.
You have to come in person.
You sign a...
But now it's not a secret.
How could you say that?
But I know I have the Loki and one of the Ironmans.
But that's all I remember.
Yeah, it's so cool.
I love...
I love Hot Toys figure.
They're like a...
They're a Hong Kong company too.
But they're so detailed.
It's just a base now.
They're really, really detailed too.
The sculpts are crazy.
Yeah, look at like the...
Like the clothes too.
The clothes are like...
Extra...
Like they're very detailed too.
I still have...
They're somewhere in the storage somewhere.
They're like somewhere in storage.
But I find it like really interesting.
I use my birthday present for this.
For Hot Toys.
Because they're very expensive too.
When I got into Hot Toys...
I would...
My dad would be like...
What do you want?
And I was like...
Take me to a secret place.
Me want to go to a secret place.
That's where I would go to.
To get my...
To get my Hot Toys pre-order.
Understand.
Yeah.
And they're very, very expensive.
So I would use my birthday present.
My birthday present for this.
Because like...
For me, when I was growing up...
My parents didn't get me like birthday gifts.
They'll just be like...
What do you want?
And then I'd be like...
I want this.
And then they'll like...
Buy it for me.
Like either on my birthday...
Or the day after my birthday.
Because they're like...
They were like...
They don't trust themselves...
On getting me on what I want.
Like...
On like...
I guess like satisfying me.
I don't know.
I guess they don't trust themselves...
To get the gift that...
They think I would want.
So they're just like...
What do you want?
And I'd be like...
I want this.
Oh, it's so cool.
I love the Secret Bay stuff.
Alright, this is when like...
This is when...
Before I collected myself.
So you know how I...
Oh my god, they have Pennywise now?
Oh my god, they have John Wick.
This is before like...
When I...
You know...
Spent all my money on buying merch of myself.
Before then, I bought merch of other people.
And now I know...
And now I know my true purpose.
Now I collect myself.
I...
I collect myself now.
That is a true collector's way.
I'm a real collector now, guys.
I was misguided.
Now I find my real purpose.
Evolution of Ego.
Oh my god, wait.
Let me show you guys.
Okay.
Transformers.
Is it Hot Toys?
What was the...
It was a Chinese company too.
Is it a Chinese company?
Starscream.
Was it Hot Toys or...
No.
It was...
It was really old.
But I still have it.
It was this one.
Oh my god.
What?
Okay.
It was a chibi figure.
Of Starscream.
I saw short of it.
But I don't know...
I don't know what company made it.
Is this one?
I have this.
Wait.
Let's see.
Um...
Does it say in the description?
I'll lay...
Oh.
It's Toy Chill.
It's Toy...
What?
Is that actually what it's called?
Does anyone know...
Is it Kid's Logic?
Oh, it could be Kid's Logic.
Kid's Logic.
Oh, it is.
I bought this at...
I bought this at Anicon.
This guy.
This guy was like...
This guy made me happy.
Look at him.
He's so tiny.
Look at this little chibi guy.
He also has like lights and everything.
Look at that.
It's so cool.
Yeah, I bought this at Anicon.
Look at him.
He's so tiny.
Okay, he's not that tiny.
But like, he's so cute.
I also have the Megatron too.
And the...
Black Convoy.
Like, oh my god.
Look at the tiny gun he has.
Look how tiny he is.
It's so cute.
Look how tiny his little gun is.
And he like lights up too.
It's so cute.
Pew, pew, pew.
I want to see him light up.
Look at him.
Oh my god.
Look at this little guy.
And then his eyes...
I also have this.
And I have this too.
I have this one because I thought it was pretty high.
But little Doki thought it was pretty high.
It's like Optimus Prime.
But evil, you know?
Whoa!
Oh my god!
I was like...
Honestly, he looks really good in black.
Not gonna lie.
Edgy Convoy.
I don't see.
Look how fucking cool he looks.
He looks so much better in black.
Versus like red and blue.
You know what?
I think I get it.
Yeah.
Look at him.
Oh my god.
Okay, look.
Look at these two together.
And like...
Okay, the red and blue...
Yeah, I mean...
Yeah, sure.
It pops.
But like...
The black though.
Oh my god.
You can tell he's a bad boy.
Alright, let's change topic.
Let's change topics here.
Alright.
Things to do in Hong Kong!
What other things should we do?
Best things to do in Hong Kong.
Alright, let's look at actual tourist destinations here.
Alright.
Depending on the day that you do decide to go up to the top of Victoria Peak on the tram...
No, that's their head.
I don't want to go...
Oh, that's cute though.
Um...
Bag.
Thank you for the super chat thing.
Thank you.
There's the peak.
And then there's the...
Oh wait, there's Lantau Island.
Now here we are at Lantau Island.
One of the most famous islands in the Hong Kong...
I know Lantau Island.
I've been to Lantau Island actually.
Fishing village.
This is a very old school fishing village.
You can feel like you're going back in time when you walk around here.
They have some tours.
Is it humid?
It is very humid over there.
Most of Hong Kong...
It is very humid.
The Tai O fishing village is definitely a blast from the past.
If you're like...
If you're from NA, you'll find it really, really, really humid.
And...
Because like that was my first experience.
Um...
When I first came back to Hong Kong as a...
When I...
Not first.
When I moved...
To Hong Kong.
From...
Well, no, actually...
Because like I had to...
We moved to China first.
Because like...
But we have to...
We have to like go through Hong Kong airport to go to Shenzhen.
And like when I came from Canada to Hong Kong airport...
When I had to first move to Shenzhen...
Um, it was very humid.
I had trouble breathing at first because I was not used to humidity as someone that lived in Canada for like most of her life at that time.
Yeah, you get like slammed up by the heat and humidity.
So if you're like, if you grew up with like Canadian type weather, it would be very humid for you.
So like for me, I know, I know like when I, when I get there, I'm gonna get like hit by the humidity if I go during the summer.
But I'm not going during the summer.
I'm gonna go during the winter.
So my body can adjust easier.
What is this?
Oh, wait, is that... I didn't know we went down to Seoul.
Wait, that's funny.
We have a Wax Museum?
I didn't know that.
That's cool.
I haven't been there.
You see, just walking around, he's very laid back and I point this out because I breathe while in the city and you're going to find that out here in Stanley.
So that's why we're pointing out this area.
Here's Stanley Market.
Oh, Stanley Market!
Now, let's talk about some of the local food.
Hong Kong food is so famous.
You've got Hianese chicken, you've got dim sum, you've got soups that are so much variety.
wonton noodle soup, you've got crispy noodle, haking duck.
Yeah, sumai!
Yeah!
And the soup is soup and beef.
They've got pork and seafood options.
As a matter of fact, some of the best are so delicious, I try it at least.
Yippee!
Where's this place?
Long, Khaifong.
It's probably numero uno.
There's so many.
Yeah, the nightlife is like really good here too.
It's like... the thing about Hong Kong is that... since it's a city... since it's a city, there's like places where like... basically... there's like... a really big nightlife.
So like the city never sleeps type deal.
Yeah, there's like a lot... huge like... because like there's always something... a place open.
I personally come down here... Oh, is that the tourist spot here?
Next up, let's take...
This is mainland China.
There's a lot more than just Temple Street.
You can also go... Temple Street?
In the afternoon, they have some luxury hotels on this side...
Does it close earlier now?
Aww...
Kowloon is actually attached...
Oh, Kowloon.
So that means you can get to Shenzhen...
Yeah!
I would...
But I would say... definitely try some of this street food.
So delicious.
I really love it.
These fish balls.
Avenue of the stars...
Now here we are...
Oh, this is a classic place.
This area.
Avenue of the stars... right here... on the Kowloon side.
Avenue of the stars is a great place to get a sunset...
This is like very common place.
...get shots of the harbor looking out towards...
Oh my god, Macau!
Macau!
You can come over here in the evening time, sunset...
I would say ideally...
I love Macau.
This is basically our Las Vegas.
For those who don't know... I talked about Macau before.
But...
Um...
But like for those who don't know...
Macau is like the Asia Las Vegas.
So like...
Like we basically have everything that...
Las Vegas has.
We even have a miniature Venice.
Um...
I...
I actually stayed...
My grandpa took me to like...
For the travel guide for Macau...
I'll put a link below...
Okay...
Let me show you guys...
Is it here?
Oh my god, look.
Oh my god, there's the...
There's like...
What is it called?
The clock.
The...
Ben clock.
It's not...
I'm tired.
It's midnight, guys.
I'm...
Big Ben.
I'm sorry.
This place is too small.
The Ben clock.
I'm sorry.
It's midnight right now.
I'm tired.
Um...
I went to this place.
In Macau.
And I actually stayed...
In the hotel up here.
Uh...
The Golden Palace.
I don't remember what it's called.
I did the gondola thing too.
Um...
But...
My grandpa booked us to stay here.
At the...
The Golden Hotel there.
To come and go.
Now let's talk about some more of these...
Yeah.
I was allowed to...
Obviously, I wasn't allowed to go into the casino.
But my parents and my grandpa did.
Because, you know, they're...
They were over 18.
And I wasn't...
I was just there for the gondolas, I guess.
I...
I guess...
I guess I was just there for the gondolas.
I don't know.
I...
I remember it being really fun.
Alright.
What else can we do?
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
What about like...
Mmm...
Um...
As a...
Okay.
How about as a local?
Things to do in Hong Kong as a local.
Maybe like...
That will narrow things down for us.
Um...
Usually, I would just like...
For food, I would definitely check out all the malls that I like to go to.
Um...
To see Venice of Hong Kong Fishing Village.
They have great Hakka and Shand food.
And the best shrimp paste in Southeast Asia.
And I would recommend Chin Chow for their congee plus lots of nice cafes.
Oh!
Thank you for the recommendation!
Uh...
Norarkle.
Thank you for the...
Thank you, thank you.
Check out West Kowloon Art Park.
West...
Kowloon...
Art...
Park.
What is that?
Alright.
Ba-dum-bum-ba.
Which I always wanna show my friends overseas.
Or even local friends.
Because...
This place has the best view of Hong Kong right now.
That's the really...
That's the public.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh!
That's pretty.
And this park is so big.
And you...
Never worry about that.
It will be packed with people.
You know, you have...
A lot of space.
You can do anything you want.
There's a dog!
I'm not bringing dad over, guys.
He is not going through a 14 hour flight.
And there are new restaurants or cafes open.
Oh, it's a new park?
It's open five years ago.
It's like...
It's this place.
And one of them is my favorite.
It's this one.
It's called...
Just...
Coffee...
Gin.
Whoa.
Nice.
Oh, it's a fancy coffee place.
Oh...
Matcha!
Dog!
The hardware of Park Park is amazing.
So you gotta have good software for it.
Oh my gosh.
Various amazing events.
Oh!
What kind of event is there?
More and more events in this place.
Suggests a yearly jazz festival on this day.
Oh!
They have products from all over the world.
That's cool.
Most importantly, locally made handcraft beer.
The most important part!
This is the one thing we're here for.
The local craft beer.
That's right!
Beerokadak!
Oh man, that's fun though.
Okay, I should really call it.
I just realized it's like...
I've been streaming for three hours.
What?
I had a fun time!
I had a fun time, everybody.
I'm planning my vacation with you guys.
I hope you guys had a lot of fun too.
Hang out with me today.
And watching...
And...
Sort of...
We were so...
Sort of low-key being a reaction channel today.
But...
It's fine.
I get one a week.
I get...
Yeah, we saw a lot of fun things...
Fun things to do.
And a lot of good places to eat too.
I'll definitely look back in the chat.
To like...
Compile some like...
Uh...
Like...
Compile all the things that I really wanna do and stuff.
Uh...
But...
Yeah!
I had a lot of fun with you guys today.
I'm tired now.
I'm eepy.
But I hope you guys had fun hanging out with me too.
Um...
Anyway guys!
I am going to...
Head to bed.
Now.
So...
As always...
Everybody...
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get them around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me...
Head to bed.
Cause...
You deserve it.
Thank you to all the Hong Kong people!
For helping me too!
And suggesting stuff.
I really appreciate it.
Uh...
For like...
Keeping me up to date on like...
What's going on over there.
And what like...
What closed down.
And like...
What's fun to do.
Um...
As a local.
So thank you guys!
Thank you for all the Hong Kong dragoons!
For helping me!
Anyway guys!
I'm gonna head out and sleep!
I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!